[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le retour du Grand Direct
autour de la réforme des retraites qui
étaient terminées ici au Sénat c'est le
7e jour de l'examen de cette réforme à
la chambre haute du Parlement avec et
bien cet article 7 qui occupe les
sénateurs depuis hier vous savez cet
article sur le décalage de l'âge de
départ de 62 à 64 ans toute la question
est de savoir quand est-ce que et bien
les sénateurs vont arriver au bout de
l'examen de cet article et pouvoir voter
sur cet article Public Sénat va tout
suivre en direct ce soir il reste
environ
38-40 amendements que il reste à
examiner d'ici la fin de l'examen de
l'article après que la droite vous le
savez a fait tomber plus d'un millier
d'amendements de la gauche c'était cette
nuit en séance la droite sénatoriale qui
n'hésite plus non plus à user de
certaines armes disponibles au Règlement
du Sénat comme l'article 38 dont on
parle beaucoup depuis 24 heures et donc
les débats avancent on va en parler avec
Mathias sarez notre journaliste Public
Sénat qui va nous suivre tout au long de
cette soirée bonsoir Mathias bonsoir
effectivement la gauche qu'elle a
censure mais on peut le dire les
amendements sont adoptés oui les
amendements avant s'il en reste chaque
fois moins Quentin et des débats qui
s'accélèrent notamment vous l'avez dit
grâce à des armes réglementaires
utilisées par la majorité sanatoriale et
notamment cet article 38 qui avait déjà
hier souvenez-vous mais le feu aux
poudres et bien il est dorénavant
omniprésent dans les débats cet article
jamais utilisé jusqu'ici il a été quatre
fois aujourd'hui une fois de la part de
Bruno Retailleau le président du groupe
LR dès le premier scrutin en fin
d'après-midi une fois par le sénateur
macroniste François Patriat et puis deux
fois par le président du groupe des
indépendants Claude malurey alors cette
utilisation elle interroge sur les bancs
de la gauche et l'écologie c'est Guy
benaroche a bien une théorie là-dessus
excuse vous avez demandé l'article 38
j'ai le droit d'exprimer ce que je pense
vous n'êtes pas obligé de me couper
voilà donc je me suis dit c'est une
autre raison quelle est cette raison et
en faisant une petite étude sur les deux
fois où vous l'avez utilisé par rapport
au fond vous ne l'avez pas utilisé on
verra si c'est confirmé par l'effet dans
le futur il me semble en fait que vous
l'utilisez mais peut-être me trompe à
partir du moment où vous estimez que le
débat devient suffisamment intéressant
et a pu à certains ordre d'arguments
auxquels vous ne souhaitez pas répondre
puisque vous ne voulez pas prolonger le
débat alors pour la commission saisie
sur le fond à savoir celle des affaires
sociales la vérité et tailleur selon
René Paul Savary l'article 38 sert à
éviter de perdre du temps face à une
stratégie de mauvaise foi
les questions précédentes Raymond de
poser le sait bien quand même le C2P
c'est pas cet article là et Madame Liman
elle sait bien aussi que les petites
pensions c'est l'article 10 donc les
réponses on les fera en fonction des
articles si on arrive à clarifier ce
débat comme ça je pense qu'on peut
éviter de sortir l'article 38 non donc
on clarifie le débat et on fait en sorte
que les questions qui se posent elles se
posent au bon moment si vous en êtes
d'accord bien entendu un article 38 qui
on le rappelle Quentin vice
principalement à limiter le nombre de
prises de parole préalable ou encore la
multiplication des explications de vote
une fluidité des débats modérés mais
indéniable merci Mathias pour toutes les
explications et donc on voit parfois ce
faux rythme qui s'installe dans
l'hémicycle avec ses discussions autour
de l'utilisation certaines armes du
règlement et par d'autres moments et
bien des vrais débats sur le fond des
sujets de la réforme des retraites
aller-retour au direct avec ces débats
qui sont en cours et donc a priori pour
encore plusieurs heures que vous allez
pouvoir suivre sur notre antenne en
direct c'est le rapport de la branche
joyeuse René Paul Sabri qu'elle a la
parole et finalement leur emploi service
c'est la raison pour laquelle il semble
plus judicieux de limiter le dispositif
de ces bonifications en tout non pas le
dispositif la limite de ces
bonifications et je crois que c'est pas
tout à fait ce que vous souhaitez donc
avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre même avec le
rapporteur mais ma vie je suis saisie
d'une demande de scrutin public sur
cette amendement pour que vous puissiez
vous préparer par l'explication de vote
le scrutin public est ouvert
et puis et bien que la gauche a perdu
des milliers d'amendements elle dépose
maintenant énormément de demandes de
scrutin public pourquoi parce que cela
permet d'occuper le terrain de continuer
à s'opposer à la réforme des retraites
en faisant perdre du temps de débat pour
rester bien sûr que le texte n'aie
jamais au bout et donc la gauche qui
demande des scrutins publics et donc au
lieu de voter à main levée il y a un
vote dans l'ensemble du scrutin on va
écouter le résultat de ce scrutin
3407 exprimés pour 93 quand 244 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté
je suis bien sur l'amendement 4294 c'est
bien ça c'est un moment de repli qui
vise à supprimer le plafonnement de
cumul de l'ensemble des bonifications à
20 trimestre
et je rappelle encore une fois les
militaires bon on en a besoin certes et
on en aura besoin encore plus bientôt et
je pense que
ce n'est pas un bon coup qu'on leur fait
avis de la commission
explication de vote je n'envoie pas
ceux qui sont favorables je suis une
demande de scrutin public
il est ouvert
voilà on le comprend maintenant tout va
se jouer sur la question du rythme
est-ce que la droite va parvenir à faire
voter l'article 7 dans les prochaines
heures dans les prochaines minutes ou
est-ce que la gauche va réussir à bien
retarder les débats à continuer à
déposer des amendements des sous
amendements provoquer des scrutins
publics des demandes d'explication de
vote pour faire en sorte de d'empêcher
le vote ou de ralentir le vote sur
l'article 7 c'est tout l'enjeu des
prochaines heures
exprimer 332 pour
81 contre 251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
et nous passons à l'amendement
4294 qui le présente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je pense qu'il
serait important de parler un petit peu
sur le fond des problèmes d'attractivité
des métiers de la fonction publique nous
sommes tous confrontés dans nos
collectivités
particulièrement dans dans la mienne les
Hauts-de-Seine sur les problèmes
d'embauche les collectivités ne peuvent
plus embaucher notamment dans l'Aide
sociale à l'enfance il y a une perte
d'attractivité très forte de tous les
métiers de la santé de la police de
l'enseignement qui est général qui due à
une perte de pouvoir d'achat très forte
depuis une vingtaine d'années qui a été
un peu compensée avec l'augmentation du
point indice mais qui reste très très
forte la question de fond que nous
pourrions nous poser ici c'est en quoi
le la retraite et le rôle de la retraite
peut être constitutif d'une meilleure
attraction du meilleur attractivité des
emplois de la fonction publique c'est
vraiment un débat de fond monsieur mixte
ce que les vitesses je je vous le redis
elles sont confrontées aujourd'hui à un
problème d'embauche qui est vraiment
diriment et donc il faut s'occuper merci
monsieur le Président alors l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur c'est
la même série de supprimer suppression
d'aller à d'alinéa les uns après les
autres donc avis des favorable
monsieur
alors je suis saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public donc si vous voulez bien
vous préparer pas de demande
d'explication de vote le scrutin est
ouvert
vous voyez c'est toi la même chose qui
se passe depuis que nous avons repris
l'antenne en direct à 22h les sénateurs
communistes qui ont déposé des
amendements les amendements sont
examinés et à chaque fois ils se
tournent vers des amendements de replis
c'est-à-dire les amendements qui
proposent des choses similaires mais
avec quelques dates qui ont été
modifiées c'était donc à chaque fois la
même chose et la commission qui refuse
et le gouvernement aussi et les scrutins
publics qui s'enchaînent
tant 344 exprimés 93 cours contre 251 et
nous passions numéro
rectifier bis madame gréaume le présente
le gouvernement
s'imagine sûrement pouvoir limiter la
colère qui gronde dans le pays en
épargnant certains régimes spéciaux de
ce projet de réforme a populaire dans
cette logique et vous prétendez prendre
en compte des spécificités pour les
policiers pour pieds surveillants ou
encore pénitentiaire ou encore les
militaires pourtant vous leur demandez
tout de même je cite de participer à
l’effort collectif j'aimerais comprendre
d'ailleurs ce qu'il y a de collectif
dans un système où seuls les
travailleurs sont à contribution quand
dans le même temps le capital et la
fortune des ultra-riches prospère sans
que vous ne leur demandez rien ce
printemps du effort collectif notre
personne monsieur le ministre pas plus
que les postures en demi-teinte quand on
regarde ce que réserve votre projet de
réforme aux militaire on voit bien que
vous n'êtes que dans les éléments de
langage les efforts que vous allez leur
demander ces deux ans de plus
concrètement c'est cela que vous ne
dites pas
car pour elle et pour celles et ceux
dont la limite d'âge est supérieure ou
égal à 57 ans vous allez décaler de deux
ans l'application de l'âge de
l'application de la décote dite carrière
longue si les militaires comme sur les
travailleurs et travailleurs votre
projet n'a qu'un seul objectif réaliser
des économies sur le dos de celles et
ceux qui se sont épuisés par une vie de
labeur par une vie de service à la
nation pourtant les spécificités du
régime des militaires tiennent à
plusieurs points essentiels monsieur le
ministre et parmi ces derniers on trouve
l'importance de manifester la
reconnaissance de la Nation à ces hommes
et ces femmes qui l'ont servi en
intégrant les corps de l'armée parce que
nous estimons que cette reconnaissance
est un devoir de l'État nous vous
demandons par cet amendement de ne pas
décaler l'application de la décote 10
carrières longues merci monsieur le
rapporteur
avis défavorables sur le ministre oui
madame la sénatrice vous me parlez
d'éléments de langage mais si vous me le
permettez je vous dis très
respectueusement il me semble que c'est
plutôt vous qui venait de déployer des
éléments de langage avec un discours
très généraliste et un amendement qui me
semble totalement à côté de la plaque de
ce qui est le système de bonification
pour les militaires parce que votre
amendement il vise à supprimer l'âge
d'annulation de la déco c'est à dire à
faire perdre tout le droit justement de
bénéfices pour les militaires je vais
ajouter un deuxième élément les
militaires leur départ avancer à la
retraite il repose sur une durée de
service et non pas contrairement à
d'autres métiers de la fonction publique
sur un âge d'ouverture des droits et
comme ce que nous faisons dans le cadre
de cette réforme c'est de modifier l'âge
d'ouverture des droits mais de laisser
inchangé et la durée de service et l'âge
d'annulation de la décote en
l'occurrence c'est là où vous tombez
complètement à côté de la plaque ça n'a
pas de conséquence justement pour les
militaires donc la meilleure manière je
crois de leur rendre honneur et il faut
le faire pour le l'engagement qui est le
leur c'est d'être précis et pointu cet
amendement retirait des droits je crois
aux militaires et donc je vous invite à
le retirer
alors je vais le retirer monsieur le
ministre mais simplement j'aurais bien
aimé que vous m'expliquez l'amendement
avant parce que sur les bonifications
vous avez pas expliqué correctement pour
vous avez juste dit contre et vous
n'avez pas dit pourquoi cette phrase
n'apparaît plus dans la loi et je vais
en profiter monsieur le Président pour
le suivant
je il y a des fendu il est défendu la
vie de la Commission
toujours la même affaire donc la vie
défavorable c'est le Ministre ce serait
identique
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public
scrutin ouvert
et voilà on voit donc cette stratégie de
la gauche qui se diversifie pour pour
continuer de gagner du temps privé de la
majorité de ces explications de vote et
bien les sénateurs de gauche multiplient
les amendements similaires avec toujours
à la clé c'est scrutin public qui font
donc gagner du temps qui commence à
agacer aussi dans la majorité
sanatoriale à chaque fois que le
président l'archet annonce inscrite un
public on entend des personnes qui
râlent et qui pensent leurs adversaires
à l'image de Bruno retaillod qui tout à
l'heure a lancé au bord de la gauche ce
n'est pas de le truc chiant ça messieurs
la parole
merci monsieur le Président le recul de
deux ans que nous évoquons depuis
quelques temps désormais s'appliquera on
l'a en partie évoqué à l'instant aux
fonctionnaires qui appartiennent aux
catégories dites actives et super
actives des catégories qui s'appliquent
aux seules agents de la fonction
publique exerçant des missions qui
représentent un risque particulier ou
des fatigue exceptionnelles afin de
bénéficier d'un départ en retraite
anticipée ces emplois publics concernent
par exemple et tout particulièrement les
agents de la pénitentiaire les agents de
la fonction publique hospitalières les
agents de police ou encore les
sapeurs-pompiers l'allongement de leur
carrière à deux années supplémentaires
représentent un recul social extrêmement
important pour des professions qui sont
pourtant unanimement reconnus comme
particulièrement difficiles et
entraînant une fatigue fatigue accrue
justifiant pleinement ces départs
anticipés avec cette réforme
des agents c'est l'argument dont vous
usez et abusez pourraient partir en
retraite plus tôt que les autres
fonctionnaires n'apportent en pas à ces
cas à ces catégories dites actives ou
super actives mais ils devront quand
même travailler deux années de plus à
des tâches particulièrement pénibles et
usantes après une carrière déjà bien
longue ajoutant que ces métiers font
aussi l'objectif sont aussi l'objet
pardon de fatigue qu'on pourrait
qualifier de morale de psychologie au
quotidien la violence le travail avec
des usagers en très grande souffrance
qui justifie à nos yeux un repas un
départ moins tardif on parle là de 700
000 personnes qui seront touchées par
cette mesure injuste si elle était
adoptée en l'état et je crois que c'est
un nouveau coup dur qui succède à celui
qui leur a déjà été porté avec la
réforme de 2011 la réforme verte qui
avait déjà décalé leur départ en
retraite anticipée pour les catégories
du super Act Ives l'âge de départ légal
devrait un autre avis ne pas être
repoussé car la pénibilité de leur
mission ne faiblit pas avis de la
commission monsieur rapporteur
effectivement le choix a été fait de
reporter l'effort collectif sur toutes
les professions et si on ne fait que
effectivement des différences les uns
par rapport aux autres on continue à
avoir des statuts différents vous êtes
dans le privé vous êtes dans le public
vous faites le même métier vous n'êtes
pas traité différemment vous êtes dans
un régime spécial c'est encore différent
c'est pas la même prise en compte de la
pénibilité ni de l'aptitude ni des
facteurs d'usure professionnelle c'est
la raison pour laquelle compte tenu que
on demande à tout le monde de faire en
sorte de travailler plus plus il y a de
personnes qui sont qui sortent de ce
dispositif plus l'effort collectif
reporte sur quelques-uns c'est pas le
choix que nous avons fait donc avis
défavorable défavorable que le
rapporteur
je suis soumis d'une demande de scrutin
public je vais explication de vote
madame Linde
chers rapporteur je suis très je partage
votre idée quand il y a un effort à
faire faudrait qu'il soit équitablement
répartis ou au moins également répartis
ce qui est pas tout à fait la même chose
sauf que avec la réforme de la retraite
de tel que vous l'engagez
toutes les prévisions ont montré
qu'en 2030
la le salaire moyen dans la fonction
dans le privé aura augmenté de 12 à 14%
et comme vous vous êtes engagé dans vos
simulations à ne pas augmenter la
participation de l'État la simulation
fait
référence à une baisse de pouvoir
d'achat de 8% des agents de la fonction
publique alors vous pouvez pas nous dire
on demande l'effort tout le monde doit
avoir la même chose puis au bout du
compte les salariés du privé en moyenne
parce qu'évidemment en moyenne ça va pas
être la même chose pour tout le monde
vont augmenter pendant que ceux du privé
vont baisser et ça c'est dans le rapport
du corps
est-ce qu'il dit oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre moi je
répondrai aux rapporteur bien sûr vous
êtes un peu d'autres crinière sur la
base sur la méthode tout le monde aligné
au même tarif et deux ans de plus pour
tout le monde on joue sur la je dirais
sur deux ans quand on fit que au à nos
concitoyens certains et ceux qui ont été
cités par notre collègue là rendre
service des services énormes et souvent
en période de crise on les met en valeur
et là finalement en les condamne au même
sort que les autres alors que ils ont
accompli des missions qui les ont usées
qui les ont fatigué mais je sais vous
allez leur parler des écoutiers nous
reparler même tarif pour tous les
métiers insaluent eux on fait des
métiers difficiles que peu de nos
concitoyens ont fait donc nous voterons
l'amendement alors saisis donc d'une
demande de
monsieur le ministre
juste un mot puisque pour agissez je
n'allonge pas la durée des débats j'ai
déjà rappelé ici les avancées que nous
apportons pour les agents les 700 000
agents des catégories actives
portabilité des droits suppression des
dégressivités des bonifications
suppression de la clause d'achèvement je
pense que elles sont nombreuses
effectivement pour renforcer les droits
de ces métiers juste à porter une
information aujourd'hui l'âge effectif
l'âge effectivement non pas l'âge
d'ouverture des droits mais là
effectivement de départ à la retraite
des catégories actives c'est déjà l'âge
d'ouverture des droits plus deux ans
donc les agents publics en l'occurrence
n'ont pas attendu ce débat là pour
partir un peu plus tard que l'âge
d'ouverture des droits qu'il aurait
accordé
bon Simon
oui je suis désolé de reprendre la
parole mais enfin il faut dans ce cas là
il faut pas il faut pas que le ministre
reparle non plus
effectivement quand on part quand on
liquide ses droits il y a toujours deux
facteurs qu'on prend en compte on prend
en compte la possibilité là je légale
d'ouverture des droits à la retraite et
on prend en compte les faits enfin la
déconne donc j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
qui sont qui a un effet multiplicateur
des carrières incomplètes et c'est
pareil effectivement pour les catégories
actives d'ailleurs je remarque que vous
défendez la les catégories actives c'est
formidable parce que vous avez toujours
dit que le la prise en compte de la
pénibilité ne devait pas conduire à
recréer les catégories actives donc
où les régimes spéciaux vous préférez
une prise en compte individuelle et non
collective
des métiers donc effectivement il y a il
y a cet effet mais je rappelle parce que
je l'ai déjà dit que c'est pas parce que
l'âge conjoncturel de départ à la
retraite est supérieure à l'âge que vous
pouvez dire que le décalage de l'âge n'a
pas d'effet puisqu'on est sur des
moyennes et tous ceux je suis désolé il
y a une partie quand même importante qui
part sur le critère de l'âge légal
c'est-à-dire ils acceptent ils
consentent enfin il consente à la décote
et j'ai pu les chiffres mais c'est de
l'ordre de 20% et c'est 20% là vous
voyez vous les obligez
là à deux enfermes donc il y a toujours
deux mécanismes mais les raisonnements
par moyenne sont un vraiment un biais un
biais de raisonnement
nous allons maintenant voter j'aurai
simplement dire que quand les ministres
n'interviennent pas vous le reprochez et
quand les ministres éclaire le débat et
bien vous leur reprochez aussi je
voudrais le rappeler quand même c'est me
semble-t-il important pour la qualité de
nos débats donc le scrutin est ouvert
et ouais normalement
on va pouvoir revenir
est-ce que quelqu'un demande encore à
voter NON
345 votants 340 exprimés 93 pour contre
252 le Sénat n'a pas adopté mais nous
passons à
rectifiés qui le présente
il est défendu il n'est pas défendu
madame lui va
monsieur le président
le recul de de deux ans de l'âge de la
retraite s'appliquera également au
fonctionnaires appartenant aux
catégories dites actives et super active
pour rappel ces deux catégories existent
depuis 1949 et nécessite 17 à 20 ans de
service pour que certains fonctionnaires
puissent en bénéficier ces catégories ne
s'appliquent qu'aux seuls agents de la
fonction publique exerçant des missions
qui présentent un risque particulier où
les fatigue exceptionnelles afin de
bénéficier d'un départ en retraite
anticipé ces emplois public concernent
particulièrement les agents de la
pénitentiaire les agents de la fonction
publique hospitalière les agents de
police ou encore les sapeurs-pompiers
l'allongement de leur carrière de deux
années supplémentaires constituent un
recul social pour ces femmes et ces
hommes dans les métiers sont unanimement
reconnus comme particulièrement
difficile et entrainent une fatigue
accrue justifiante pleinement un départ
anticipés avec cette réforme certes ces
agents pourraient partir en retraite
plutôt que les autres fonctionnaires
n'appartenant pas aux catégories des
actives ou super active mais ils devront
tout de même travailler deux années de
plus à des tâches pénible et usantes
avec une carrière déjà bien longue ainsi
ce sont 700 000 personnes qui seront
touchées par cette mesure injuste si
elle était adoptée en l'état c'est un
nouveau coup dur porté à ses
fonctionnaires après celui de 2011 et la
réforme verte qui a décalé l'âge de
départ en retraite anticipée de 55 à 57
ans pour les catégories dites super
actives l'âge de départ légal sera
repoussée de 50 à 52 ans alors que la
pénibilité de leur mission ne faiblit
pas c'est pourquoi nous demandons la
suppression de
cette alors l'avis de la commission
Monique Lubin vous nous avez habitué à
travailler correctement vos amendements
ça fait 10 amendements que l'on présente
de suppression et la moitié 2
aboutissent à l'inverse de ce que vous
souhaitez il n'y a pas eu de
modification des dispositions pour la
durée de de maintien au service de
service elle est restée malgré les
augmentations d'âge elle est restée au
même nombre d'années en conséquence vous
demandez de faire disparaître cette
dispositions vous ne souhaitez pas quand
même qui travaille plus longtemps dans
ce type d'activité donc je pense qu'il
est plus raisonnable de retirer cet
amendement
il est maintenu
il est maintenu donc on a un double avis
défavorable monsieur gilet voulait
expliquer votre vote pour éclairer
l'assemblée ainsi que Monsieur Kerrouche
comprends monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur vous apportez des éléments
j'ai un peu de difficulté à pouvoir
véritablement les vérifier sur le fond
mais je voudrais souligner deux aspects
le premier aspect c'est qu'en fait le
référentiel de ce projet la stratégie de
la gauche qui continue de dérouler cette
usure en multipliant les amendements en
faisant un travail d'orfèvre vraiment en
décortiquant le texte amendement par
amendement pendant quasiment corps de
métier après corps de métier alors là on
est principalement sur des corps de
métiers issus de la fonction publique il
y a par exemple plus de longs échanges
notamment sur le régime des égoutiers on
a notamment entendu le communiste Pascal
ça vole Delhi les défendre longuement et
changer avec le ministre de la Fonction
publique Stanislas Rigo c'est un long
tunnel où il y a également aussi des
amendements qui sont moins défendus un
petit peu moins travaillés on a par
exemple vu la sénatrice Michel gréaume
quasiment pas défendre ses amendements
on voit donc c'est de gauche qui use de
cette tactique également abuse et use
aussi des scrutins publiques qui ont le
sait font gagner du temps qui agace ici
lors d'un scrutin il y a très peu de
temps on a également vu se multiplier
des explications de vote et à ce
moment-là Bruno retailleur même pris son
règlement intérieur en main très à des
gainer l'article 38 qui ont le sait peut
clore les débats on le voit donc cette
stratégie qui continue d'user à droite
mais la gauche qui continue à cette
cette manière de gagner encore un petit
peu de temps dans ces débat il reste à
présent un petit peu moins de 30
amendements avant le vote sur cet
article 7
le président monsieur le ministre tout à
l'heure le rapporteur
a dit quelque chose qui est
éminemment faux vous avez dit notre
choix c'est de faire en sorte que on
allonge de manière globale l'âge de la
retraite et qu'on demande le même effort
à tout le monde et on est là au cœur au
cœur d'un des problèmes fondamentaux de
cette de cette réforme parce que
justement ce qui compte c'est ce qu'on
apprend en général aux étudiants en
première année c'est pas la moyenne
c'est l'écart à la moyenne et vous
faites comme si vous faites comme si
passez de 62 à 64 ans
ça faisait la même chose pour tout le
monde on sait très bien que l'espérance
de vie et l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé et corréler à deux choses d'abord
aux revenus d'une part et d'autre part à
la CSP et vous nous expliquer très
gentiment que les conséquences sont les
mêmes pour chacun c'est faux
fondamentalement faux et de fait la
réforme sera inégale et concernera plus
certains que d'autres par ailleurs ne
pas tenir en compte la spécificité de
certaines fonctions qu'on encense par
ailleurs comme celle de pompiers dont on
a encore eu besoin c'est relativement
particulier mais au-delà de ça c'est
l'erreur de raisonnement sur lequel
repose cette réforme c'est de faire
comme si nous étions tous pareils alors
que nous sommes fondamentalement tous
différents et dans des situations
sociales qui sont nettement marquées et
nettement différenciées si je vais
consulter ceux qui sont favorables à son
amendement
à cet abonnement de manifestant devant
la main
à vie contraire
abstention il n'est pas adopté et non
pas l'amendement
4303 rectifié bis madame a poursu poli
merci monsieur le Président notre
amendement porte sur les catégories
actives et super active de
fonctionnaires pour rappel c'est deux
catégories existent depuis 1949 et
nécessite 17 à 20 ans de service pour
que certains fonctionnaires puissent en
bénéficier c'est catégories s'appliquent
qu'aux seuls agents de la fonction
publique exerçant des missions qui
présentent un risque particulier ou des
fatigue exceptionnelles afin de
bénéficier donc d'un repas d'un départ
excusez-moi anticipé ces emplois public
concernent particulièrement les agents
de la pénitentiaire les agents de la
fonction publique hospitalière les
agents de police ou encore les
sapeurs-pompiers agent des peaux
mortuaires agent d'entretien des usines
d'incinération des ordures ménagères
ménagères
pompier professionnel agent des services
de désinfection fossoyeur blanchisseur
et blanchisseuse des hôpitaux avec cette
réforme il et elle verront leur âge
légal de départ reculé de deux ans pour
atteindre 59 ans quand on personnel
actif de la police nationale au
personnel de surveillance de
l'administration pénitentiaire aux
agents des réseaux souterrains des
égouts encore aux agents du corps des
identificateurs de l'institut
médico-légal de la préfecture de police
de Paris le recul de l'âge de départ
sera repoussé à 64 ans franchement ce
n'est pas acceptable mais même là tout à
l'heure Pascal ça voldei vous a pris un
exemple celui des égoutiers j'en ai cité
d'autres il a essayé de vous faire
réagir au-delà de ce que nous sommes et
les uns et les autres dans cette
hémicycle et puis évidemment et bien
rien vous vous obstinez vous continuez
et on vit franchement je pense parfois
dans deux mondes parallèles alors l'avis
de la commission monsieur
auparavant une ministre oui en
l'occurrence madame la sénatrice vous
conclure en disant qu'on vit dans le
monde parallèle moi je vis dans le monde
réel des fonctionnaires et des agents
publics et en l'occurrence des agents
publics contractuels puisque
l'amendement que vous proposez il
supplie supprime les alinéas qui je
crois devrait vous conduire à retirer
cet amendement les alinéas que vous
supprimez dans l'article c'est une
avancée pour les contractuels de la
fonction publique puisque ce que nous
faisons avec ce projet de loi c'est de
faire en sorte que des agents
contractuels
qui font parfois le même métier que des
agents qui sont en catégorie active et
qui de bénéficient ni du C2P ni du
bénéfice de la catégorie active et bien
puisse bénéficier après cette réforme
quand elle sera adoptée du fait que
leurs allées de service passaient en
tant que contractuel soit comptabilisé
dans leur durée de service c'est une
avancée pour les agents de la fonction
publique et il s'avère je le prends
comme illustration justement de
l'intérêt du dialogue social que nous
avons eu que c'était une revendication
ancienne des organisations syndicales et
que nous avons donné suite à cette
revendication dans le cadre de la
préparation de ce projet de loi faire en
sorte que les années passées en tant
contractuel puissent être comptabilisés
dans la durée de service qui leur
permettra de partir un peu plus tôt
c'est cela que vous venez de supprimer
en venant supprimer les alinés à 61 63
donc je recommande le retrait de cet
amendement
il est maintenu
oui écouter on a vraiment du mal à
croire tout ce que vous nous racontez
depuis tout à l'heure on va vérifier on
regardera mais en tous les cas on ne
vous croit pas parce que on a compris
que de toute façon votre lettre motive
depuis des jours et des jours c'est fait
c'était de faire travailler les gens
plus longtemps or vous nous excusez vous
essayez depuis tout à l'heure quand
c'est pas à Monique Lubin ou à Raymond
poncer Monge ou à moi-même de nous
donner des leçons écoutez on n'a pas de
leçon à recevoir de vous
oui la courtoisie étant une valeur
sénatoriale il faut être attentif madame
Linde pour expliquer son vote
et déjà entendu plusieurs fois
l'argument de monsieur le ministre sur
la continuité des contractuels qui quand
ils viendraient à Jean pourraient
bénéficier de leur année de
contractuelle et c'est vrai que c'est
plutôt une avancée mais mais
j'en reviens au nombre de contractuels
dans la fonction publique
parce que de la même manière que je
reprends mon raisonnement sur le fait
que la participation de l'État au
financement des retraites va être
stabilisés donc je vous rappelle qu'en
2070 ça fait presque plus de la moitié
du déficit public est lié au fait du
manque de recettes par l'État vous ne
m'avez pas répondu là-dessus
et la masse salariale maintenue c'est à
la fois le gel c'est à la fois on crée
pas des emplois mais c'est aussi en tout
cas pas des emplois stables de la
fonction publique et on va avoir la
multiplication des postes de
contractuels qui vont continuer à
déstabiliser une fonction publique
aurait besoin d'être valorisée je
rajoute à cela l'argument sur la CNRACL
vous a pas échappé que tout ce qui avait
on a eu le débat je ne veux pas être
longue sur ce point mais nous avons eu
le débat sur la CNRACL et qu'est-ce
qu'on a pu découvrir et mettre en
exergue c'est que en disons en serrant
le la gorge des collectivités locales
c'était la façon dont vous pouviez
réduire la masse salariale de la
fonction publique territoriale en
réduisant les services publics et la
boucle est bouclée alors une toute
petite avancée pour quelques
contractuels qui seront titularisés et
la masse la masse de contractualité qui
vont se poursuivre voir se développer
franchement le compte n'y est pas
merci monsieur le Président alors vous
dites souvent effectivement que la durée
de service active vous l'avez pas
indiqué vous avez raison mais en deux
réformes en deux réformes on est passé
de durée de service active 15 ans
de 15 ans à la anticipé 55 ans
c'est-à-dire on pouvait partir à 15 ans
après 15 ans à 55 ans première réforme
17 ans à 57 ans votre réforme 17 ans à
59 ans donc effectivement vous dégradez
quand même la genticiper puisqu'il passe
de 57 à 59 vous ne dégradez pas la durée
de service active vous glissez à 17 ans
alors que la réforme précédente avait
dégradé les deux facteurs et je voudrais
vous dire que ne pas dégrader un
indicateur c'est pas ce que j'appelle
moi un progrès social c'est comme la
décote vous la dégradez pas l'âge de la
décote c'est comme la validité
permanente que vous avez laissée au même
âge et vous croyez tellement qu'une non
dégradation est un progrès social que y
compris je l'ai déjà dit vous mettez la
validité permanente qui n'a pas qui a eu
son son âge maintenu vous le mettez en
mesure
d'accompagnement en mesure sociale alors
j'ai le temps là maintenant de dire
voilà un syndicaliste qui avait signé un
accord très très dégradé c'est pour ça
et à qui je disais mais tu as signé
quand même quelque chose tout va mal il
m'a dit oui mais nous avons gagné par
rapport à ce que nous pouvions perdre
nous avons gagné par rapport à ce que
nous pouvions perdre c'est ce que ce que
vous nous dites souvent c'est à dire ce
que vous n'avez pas perdu c'est un
progrès social public
il est ouvert
plus personnellement à voter
le scrutin avec
345 votants 343 exprimés pour 93 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté nous allons
passer à l'examen de 5 amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
d'abord l'amendement 248 de Monsieur
Pacaud merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur messieurs les
ministres collègues cet amendement vise
par l'abrogation d'un article du code de
l'éducation à corriger une injustice à
rétablir l'équité entre les professeurs
des écoles et les enseignants du
secondaire quant à l'âge légal
d'ouverture de leurs droits à la
retraite concrètement depuis 91 1991 un
professeur des écoles ne peut prendre ne
peut pas prendre sa retraite en cours
d'année il doit aller jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire ce qui n'est pas le cas
de son collègue du secondaire donc
concrètement vous avez deux personnes
qui sont nées le 5 septembre le
professeur des écoles il ira jusqu'au
début du mois de juillet suivant alors
que son collègue pourra rendre qui est
professeur en collège pourra ranger son
ordinateur ses cahiers ses crayons et
faire son pot de départ le 5 septembre
c'est une mesure d'équité qui est
attendue par tous les professeurs des
écoles et réclamé par les syndicats
1910 monsieur lévrier le présente
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement comme la très bien défendu
mon collègue Paco c'est un souci
d'égalité de traitement essentiellement
du second degré puisque c'est amendement
visa supprimer la disposition qui oblige
les enseignants du premier degré à
poursuivre leur activité jusqu'à la fin
d'un scolaire lorsque ces derniers ont
réuni les conditions de départ en
retraite durant cette même année je
n'oublie pas mes 30 ans passer au
service de l'enseignement et je profite
de cette prise de parole pour saluer le
travail des enseignants leur dévouement
leur engagement au service des jeunes
qui sont et seront la France de demain
c'est amendement qui FISE à faciliter
leur départ en retraite va dans le sens
d'une meilleure prise en compte de leur
parcours et d'une plus grande équité
merci beaucoup
alors nous avions en amendement 2255 de
Madame sur le groupe qui était identique
et retiré
un amendement de 1954
rectifiés qui le présente Madame Monnier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre Michel collègue donc ça a déjà
été dit en fait on supprime l'article
921-4 du code de l'éducation qui
contraint les enseignantes et
enseignants du premier degré à se
maintenir en activité jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire lorsqu'ils ont atteint
au cours de cette même année les
conditions de départ à la retraite alors
d'abord je me réjouis vraiment que cette
demande de suppression soit portée par
de nombreux collègues au sein de cette
hémicycle elle vise en effet à corriger
une inégalité qui n'a que trop perturbé
et qui si elle n'est pas aujourd'hui
remise en question conduira de fait des
personnels à se maintenir en poste
au-delà de 64 ans une double peine alors
qu'il est elles sont les plus nombreux à
partir avec une décote parmi l'ensemble
des personnels de l'Éducation nationale
par moins de 34% non seulement 10%
d'entre eux partent avec une des côtes
de moins de 5 % ce départ avant d'avoir
atteint le taux plein et bien sûr lié à
l'impossibilité de partir en cours de
l'année scolaire mais il doit aussi nous
interroger plus largement sur la
nécessité d'améliorer les conditions de
travail de nos enseignantes et de nos
enseignants ainsi que l'aménagement de
leur fin de carrière j'invite d'ailleurs
le gouvernement à s'en saisir en lien
avec les partenaires sociaux
je suis verdict et monsieur le Président
Monsieur le monsieur le ministre chers
collègues effectivement les instituteurs
on les appelle maintenant les
professeurs des écoles sont je crois
bien les seuls actifs à pas pouvoir
choisir leur date précise de départ à la
retraite en clair il ne parte à la
retraite qu'au terme d'une année
scolaire complexe c'est-à-dire le 31
août bien sûr il est essentiel de
d'assurer la stabilité le suivi annuel
du corps-roseignant près des élèves mais
un changement d'enseignant s'il est bien
anticipé ça ne sera pas source
d'instabilité d'autant que l'État ont
changé et l'époque de l'instituteur seul
dans une classe unique n'est plus le
modèle dominant loin de là les
conditions d'aujourd'hui dans la grande
majorité des écoles primaires le permet
de sans difficulté imaginons un
professeur des écoles on l'appellera à
aller au hasard Jean-Pierre liégeois
avec sa date anniversaire au 15
septembre pour un départ à 64 ans il
devra compter un an de plus pour assurer
un service
mon service jusqu'à la fin de l'année
scolaire donc un des parents en réalité
à 65 ans aujourd'hui donc du fait de
cette règle du 31 août ce sont quand
même ça a des conséquences très
pratiques et difficiles parce que c'est
son 34 % des personnels du premier degré
qui partent avec une décote et ce nombre
est nettement plus important que leurs
collègues du second degré c'est le signe
de quoi c'est le signe que beaucoup de
professeurs des écoles du fait de
l'impossibilité de partir à la retraite
en cours d'année scolaire sont en
quelque sorte acculés à partir plutôt à
la retraite pour ne pas faire l'année de
trop pour leur santé et pour éviter trop
de pénibilité au travail c'est dur en
fin de carrière donc il s'agit je crois
de lever cette contrainte UNIQUE et
anachronique alors
madame
merci monsieur le Président en
complément de ce que viennent de dire
les collègues je voudrais effectivement
insister sur le fait que les professeurs
des écoles sont les seuls qui ne peuvent
pas partir à le jour où ils ont choisi
en retraite et qu'ils doivent faire une
année complète jusqu'au 31 août
ça les injustices et les inégalités avec
leurs collègues du second degré ont été
pointés il faut savoir que les
professeurs d'écoles partent en moyenne
deux ans avant ceux du second degré pour
les raisons qui ont été expliquées c'est
que c'est un métier lui aussi
usant et que les enseignants ne veulent
pas faire l'année de trop qui peut
parfois les conduire à des catastrophes
et donc en gros ils partent pour les
hommes un peu plus de 61 ans pour les
femmes un tout petit peu plus de 60 ans
c'est des parts se font ça a été
expliqué avec des décotes entières un
tiers des profs d'école partent avec des
décotes et je crois que nous vivons à un
moment de manque d'attractivité une
crise de recrutement des enseignants et
qu'effectivement corriger cette
inégalité serait de nature à renforcer
l'attractivité de ce métier merci au vu
de la Commission sur monsieur rapporteur
ces amendements
identiques puis un amendement un peu
différent que la morale
cette alignement sur l'ensemble des
professeurs des enseignants simplement
j'ai une question à poser
messieurs les ministres qu'en pensent
monsieur le ministre de l'Éducation
quand on remplacement quand un
enseignant ça va s'en va au milieu d'une
année scolaire est-ce que vous avez des
propositions nous formuler merci
monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le Président
vous doutez bien que c'est évidemment
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Papé Ndiaye que cette mesure a
été discutée et je peux vous confirmer
que le gouvernement sera favorable à
adopter cette amendement et c'est le
souhait du ministre de l'éducation
nationale mais vous posez la bonne
question qui est celle au fond de
l'organisation des établissements
scolaires c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous menons d'ores et déjà un travail
avec le secrétaire général du ministère
avec la direction des ressources
humaines du ministère pour rendre cette
mesure effectivement et pour laisser la
liberté je le dis aussi au professeur
pour pouvoir continuer jusque à la fin
de l'année scolaire et leur laisser
évidemment le libre choix et je pense
que d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
professeurs du primaire feront le choix
de continuer à travailler et d'être
devant leur classe jusqu'à la fin de
l'année mais c'est dans cet état
d'esprit là que nous devons rendre cette
mesure qui est une belle avancée qui
vient mettre
fin à une injustice effective pour
l'ensemble des professeurs je crois que
cette mesure est attendue et donc je
vous invite à l'adopter merci
je vais consulter par avant attendez
monsieur salmon a demandé à expliquer
son vote et Madame Monnier
merci monsieur le Président
regardons un petit peu en arrière
les professeurs des écoles dont on parle
aujourd'hui était avant des instituteurs
il était un service actif il partait et
c'est pas si vieux que ça il partait à
55 ans
ensuite on est passé à 57 ans
aujourd'hui le professeur des écoles
72 ans alors là c'est vrai qu'on est un
peu grand prince on se dit aujourd'hui
et bah oui on va les laisser partir et
bien en cours d'année mais ça rejoint un
peu ce que disait ma collègue Raymond
Poncet c'est-à-dire que en fin de compte
on perd on perd et en fin de compte au
féminine que et bien ce sont des
avancées des avancées sociales non on a
une dégradation qui est terrible on le
voit au niveau des enseignants du
primaire qui sont dans un mal-être je
vais dire pratiquement absolu avec des
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
avec des arrêts qui sont de plus en plus
fréquents et des moyens de remplacement
qui sont pas toujours à la hauteur avec
effectivement des classes qui sont
si ce n'est surchargé du moins fort
rempli avec de nombreux enfants avec des
troubles du comportement effectivement
on a une usure une usure terrible de ces
enseignants qui sont eux aussi en
première ligne et que l'on oublie bien
souvent alors je pense que il faut voter
bien entendu cette amendement mais
quelque part on est dans un pays parce
que on n'a pas pris en compte toutes ces
difficultés qui s'accumulent aujourd'hui
merci
monsieur le Président je complèterai les
propos de mon collègue par aussi le
salaire des enseignants qui est bien
moins attractif et qui s'est
terriblement dégradé pendant les années
et je voudrais aussi revenir un petit
peu sur les autres paramètres vecteurs
de stress pour ces personnel qui
manquent parfois aussi de soutien de la
part de la direction de leur hiérarchie
une réalité qui incarne bien le chiffre
terrible de la dernière enquête au CDE
seul 4% des professeurs des écoles
considèrent que leur métier est valorisé
et revenir aussi sur le remplacement
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir les
remplacer mais quand même un départ à la
retraite ça s'anticipe c'est une date
qui est prévue donc je vois pas pourquoi
ce serait une difficulté pour organiser
le remplacement alors maintenant je
consulte ceux qui sont favorables à
l'adoption de cette amendement qui a
reçu un avis fera du Gouvernement et la
commission a été éclairée une manifeste
enlevant la main
et il faut tomber le dernier
voilà quatre amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement
3627 madame poncemonge merci Monsieur
Président je vous invite à garder ce
grand enthousiasme unanime
on a beaucoup parlé de l'impact de cet
article 7 sur des métiers je voudrais
quand même avant qu'il ne soit minuit
vous parlez de l'impact sur les femmes
cette réforme nous le disons est une
réforme anti-féministe selon le rapport
d'information fait au nom de la
délégation au droit des femmes du Sénat
d'attente 2013 toutes les réformes sur
les retraites ont pénalisé les femmes et
celles-ci ne fait pas exception alors un
facteur indéfacteurs alors
qu'aujourd'hui les femmes travaillent en
moyenne 7 mois de plus que les hommes
avec cette réforme elles vont en moyenne
devoir travailler 9 mois de plus alors
que c'est 5 pour les hommes cela dépend
des générations vous me direz mais c'est
toujours toujours dans ce sens plus ou
moins mais toujours au détriment des
femmes un exemple pour la génération 80
l'impact pour les femmes sera de 8 mois
d'allongement pour les hommes ça sera de
4 mois je vous invite à calcul
mathématique ces deux fois plus et je
vais vous donner un autre calcul de
cette de cet effet
de l'allongement si on
exclut les 67 ans ou les femmes je vous
le rappelle partent deux fois plus
puisqu'elle elles attendent de le taux
plein si on exclut donc les 67 ans et si
on exclut aussi ceux qui ne sont pas
touchés la validité j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure si on excuse ces deux catégories
les femmes vont devoir travailler 14
mois de plus et 11 mois pour les hommes
donc c'est un des facteurs mais c'est
pas le seul nous en reparlerons lors du
minimum contributif c'est un des
facteurs qui fait que les économistes le
disent 60% de la réforme 60% des
économies vont peser sur les femmes si
ça c'est pas une réforme anti féministe
je vous demande ce que c'est alors vous
avez un amendement suivant madame pour
Simon 3597
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président c'est moi
qui vais profiter de cet amendement
puisque comme vous l'avez constaté
toutes et tous de nombreuses sous
amendements qui étaient précédemment des
amendements ont été déclarés
irrecevables je profite donc de cette
occasion pour reprendre on va dire la
main sur un certain de nombre de métiers
dont la pénibilité
est tout à fait présente les auxiliaires
de puériculture et les ambulanciers deux
métiers passionnants mais aussi
physiquement et psychologiquement
usant
porté d'enfants tâches répétitives pour
les auxiliaires de vie en puériculture
des conditions dégradées
occupées à 97% par des femmes avec des
postures pénibles qui finissent par user
les corps
pour les ambulanciers des horaires
décalés des conditions dégradées qui
font qu'il manque aujourd'hui
15000 ambulanciers du fait d'une grande
vague de démission
ce sont des professionnels fatigués
devenus parfois inapte qui parfois
jettent l'éponge alors que ces métiers
sont cruciaux c'est des métiers ce sont
des métiers vitaux pour notre société
pour toutes ces raisons l'allongement de
la durée des cotisations et incompatible
avec les contraintes de ces métiers
alors je sais que parler de métiers par
les gens énervent parfois quelques
personnes dans des rangs à droite ici et
que certains préfèrent parler de
chiffres et de statistiques et ne pas
voir que derrière se trouve des femmes
et des hommes en chair et en os ces
chiffres vont faire payer très cher ces
deux années supplémentaires
alors
voilà 22h55 nous sommes en direct sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat l'occasion de
faire un petit point d'étape sur
l'avancée des débats nous sommes
toujours dans l'examen de l'article 7
celui sur la mesure d'âge et on va
retrouver mathiasaray en tribune de
presse Mathias dites-nous tout que se
passe-t-il en hémicycle alors où on se
parle écoutez Quentin il reste un peu
plus de 25 amendements à présent à
examiner alors effectivement la gauche a
des tricoté les corps de métiers pour
faire durer les débats mais pas toujours
pour gagner du temps il y a eu des vrais
débats de fonds sur les égoutiers
défendus par Pascal ça vole Delhi
également sur la possibilité de pouvoir
prolonger la période pour racheter ces
périodes de stage ou d'ailleurs
l'écologie se Raymond de penser Monge a
obtenu gain de cause ou encore comme à
l'instant avec la possibilité pour les
enseignants de partir en retraite en
cours d'année scolaire alors le rythme
d'examen est rapide malgré tout la
Commission et le gouvernement
n'interviennent que brièvement et la
gauche n'abuse pas des explications de
vote peut-être d'ailleurs à cause du
coup près de l'article 38 Quentin merci
Mathias c'est donc effectivement il y a
bien des amendements qui sont adoptés un
rythme de croisière et tout semble pour
le pour l'instant et bien se passer
convenablement dans l'hémicycle mais
voilà il y a les rumeurs qui bruisent
sur le fait qu'il pourrait y avoir de
nouveaux coups de théâtre dans la soirée
ce sont des centaines de milliers de
jeunes dont nous avons besoin pour
assurer la relève dans le monde agricole
d'ailleurs la question de la
transmission est en soi un véritable
sujet de portée nationale il nous
apparaît donc évident qu'il faudrait
améliorer substantiellement les
conditions de vie des agriculteurs
augmenter leur pension et donner donc
plus d'attractivité au métier c'est
l'inverse que nous faisons et ce n'est
pas une bonne chose du point de vue de
notre souveraineté agricole et
alimentaire merci de votre attention
voilà pour ce monde
play
il voulait bien préparer vos amendements
puisque pardonnez-moi
monsieur l'abbé oui monsieur le
Président de chers collègues je vais
vous parler de par cet amendement des
liens entre la vie politique locale et
les retraites
parmi les conséquences délétères de la
réforme nous pouvons compter l'impact
sur la vie politique locale en effet
lors des dernières élections municipales
l'âge moyen des nouveaux maires étaient
de 58,9 années l'Association des maires
de France notent que les mers sont de
plus en plus âgés en 2020
55,3% des mers avaient plus de 60 ans
après le dernier scrutin local
évidemment cette cette réforme ne va pas
arranger les choses de la même manière
la
moindreissement du tissu associatif est
à craindre selon une étude de la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse datant
de 2013 un dirigeant d'associations sur
deux est un retraité le passage à la
retraite favorise la vie associative
puisque chez les 55 à 65 ans le taux de
participation des retraités est
supérieur à celui des non retraités
38% des retraités tous âges confondus
sont adhérents à au moins une
association selon une étude encore entre
2010 et 2019 pour conclure le taux
d'aménagement
à l'engagement à diminuer chez les plus
âgés parmi les causes les plus probables
d'une baisse de l'engagement de
l'augmentation de l'âge du départ à la
retraite je vous remercie alors l'avis
de la commission
oui là encore mais chers collègues sont
des amende suppression d'alinéa et dans
lequel la présentation
n'est pas d'une grande évidence merci au
niveau du groupe
pour l'amendement numéro
3580 n'en parlons pour l'amendement
présenté au nom de Madame assassy pour
notre collègue effectivement
sa présentation correspond tout à fait à
l'objet de l'amendement par contre
madame poncer Monge vous nous avez
présenté un discours forte intéressant
bien entendu comme d'habitude mais qui
est plus une parole prise pour nous
souligner la position que vous défendez
mais qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'amendement vous proposez de supprimer
des et des alinés à vous nous parlez
dans l'objet d'une meilleure répartition
des richesses c'est intéressant des
milliers des milliardaires français et
puis également du rétablissement de la
retraite à 60 ans c'est quand même
extraordinaire on voit bien les
difficultés de l'équilibre d'un système
par répartition et vous restez encore
ancré dans ce type de proposition
c'est pas c'est pas sincère quand même
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens on sait
très bien que ça peut plus se passer
comme ça c'est la raison pour laquelle
soyons attentifs on sent bien que la
renéo a tourné c'est toujours le même
discours et véritablement ce type
d'amendement pourrait être interprété
par certains comme de l'obstruction donc
soyez attentif à vos exposés de motifs
merci Monsieur le Ministre du socle
vous nous avez parlé de la situation des
femmes et c'est un sujet évidemment
majeur vous nous avez parlé de la
situation des élus locaux or les
amendements que vous avez présenté
suppriment des alinéas qui concernent
pour les deux premiers les retraités
d'agriculture et pour le dernier la
retraite des demandeurs d'emploi il y a
un grand écart entre ce dont vous avez
parlé et ce que vous proposez par les
amendements et par ailleurs dans ces
amendements s'ils étaient adoptés il y
aurait qu'un seul résultat de justement
fragiliser le régime de retraite des
exploitants agricoles et des demandeurs
d'emploi donc la vie est évidemment
défavorable
alors je vais consulter
oui merci monsieur le Président tu es un
peu surpris par ce que vient de dire
monsieur le ministre enfin c'est pas la
première fois qu'on est un peu surpris
je crois que Joël Labbé a insisté sur un
point extrêmement important et il y a
dans les conseils municipaux des
communes rurales beaucoup justement de
regret de retraités du monde agricole
cette retraite fait alors que la
décennie donne à soixantaine c'est
vraiment la décennie de l'investissement
dans la vie associative et dans la vie
municipale nous savons que notre système
démocratique il fonctionne sur
l'investissement de ces jeunes retraités
dans les conseils municipaux nous savons
tous qu'on a eu du mal y compris dans
des communes moyennes avoir plus d'une
liste sur des élections y compris des
communes à 10 15000 habitants ça c'est
notre réalité si vous partez à la
retraite après 64 ans à partir 63 ans
vous vous projetez six ans après vous
projetez dans la décennie d'après et
vous hésitez à vous investir dans la vie
municipale et vous vous investissez
moins longtemps dans la vie associative
monsieur le ministre votre réforme avec
une logique comptable et Monsieur Savary
vient d'avoir une logique comptable qui
en plus passe pour silence le
déséquilibre entre les revenus du
capital et les revenus du travail tels
qu'ils ont évolué depuis 30 ans les
passants sur ce point votre votre
réforme monsieur le ministre en ne
comptant pas l'ensemble des coûts pour
la société française est en train
d'appauvrir la société française elle
est en train de fragiliser la société
française et ne pas entendre l'ensemble
des coûts induits par cette réforme est
va être absolument catastrophique dans
les prochaines années y compris pour
notre vie démocratique locale
oui madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je vais une explication de
vote sur les amendements présentés par
notre collègue Raymond de poncemonge et
elle a raison puisqu'on est le 8 mars
donc il s'agit pas de faire ici le
concours de la plus ou du plus pénalisé
par cette réforme mais dire que cette
réforme ne corrige en rien les
inégalités salariales et les inégalités
de pension est une réalité et ça va
dégrader encore la situation des femmes
les chiffres sont clairs parmi les
retraités nés en 1950 un tiers n'était
ni en emploi ni au chômage l'année
précédant la retraite c'est 37 % des
femmes pour 28% des hommes et entre 55
et 65 ans chers collègues on se trouve
souvent dans des situations
particulières qui fait que des parents
âgés dépendants nécessite de prendre du
temps sur des carrières et il se trouve
aussi qu'entre 55 et 65 ans des enfants
âgés avec des petits enfants demandent
aussi du temps au grand-parents pour
prendre voilà pour répondre à l'absence
parfois de pénurie d'accueil de la
petite enfance donc oui je voterai les
amendements présentés par Madame ponce
bien je consulte ceux qui ont reçu un
double avis défavorable sur le
3627 ceux qui sont pour le manifestants
devant la main
la vie contraire
alors je suis saisi demande de scrutin
public
pour deux amendements identiques
3597 et le
40004 c'est le groupe communiste qui
nous les demandes je vais
consulter le scrutin est ouvert
nouveau scrutin public que vous suivez
en direct sur l'antenne de public Sénart
la gauche sénatoriale qui utilise ses
scrutins publics pour gagner un petit
peu de temps puisque au lieu de voter
par main levée on vote avec des cartes
électroniques ça prend donc une minute
ou deux le temps de récapituler il reste
une vingtaine d'amendements avant la fin
de l'examen de l'article 7 donc toute la
question de savoir si les sénateurs vont
voter sur l'ensemble de cet article 7
sur la mesure d'âge d'ici à 1h30 date
heure limite ce soir pour ces débats
[Musique]
pour 249 contre le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons au vote sur le 3500 98
ceux qui sont favorables sur l'adoption
de manifeste on le voit la main
avec contraire il n'est pas adopté
nous avons examiné deux amendements
identiques ensuite
madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors moi
j'aimerais intervenir pour oui pour dire
à messieurs les ministres que tout comme
le directeur de la CNAV je ne crois pas
le groupe écologiste ne croit pas à
l'effet horizon
car les études se multiplient et sont
unanimes la réforme de 2010 a été
délétère pour l'emploi des seniors
selon l'Insee le report de l'âge 62 ans
s'est traduit par une hausse du taux
d'emploi à 60 ans de 14 points certes et
je le redis c'est beaucoup aussi les
faits de la noria générationnelle mais
bon bref mettons 14 points grâce à cette
réforme mais du taux de chômage souvent
de longue durée de 13 points et de 7
points pour la validité
l'inédit qui a sorti une étude il y a
quelque chose quelques jours qui montre
qu'elle a provoqué une hausse des
allocataires de la surrend chômage de
100 000 personnes le pic des ruptures de
contrat à 59 ans et net dans cette étude
et n'épargne personne selon une étude de
l'Apec 81% des 112000 cadres de plus de
55 ans qui sont aujourd'hui au chômage
ont été licenciés et ce même sur le
rapporteur ni un CDI senior
on peut douter que la seule exonération
des cotisations familles va les faire
réembaucher ni un index Seigneur
Seigneur Seigneur pardon qui changeront
cette donne actuellement 1,4 millions de
seniors ne sont ni en emploi ni en
retraite les études l'ont montré le
report de l'âge à 64 ans c'est 150000
personnes de plus par an au RSA enfin
dans les minimaires sociaux ou au
chômage les 865 000 chômeurs seniors
longue durée vont partir de cette
réforme par le déplacement de leur sas
de précarité le déplacement je dis bien
de deux ans de plus et pas l'annulation
par l'effet d'horizon auquel vous croyez
ensuite un amendement 435 qui qui le
présente Madame linman
oui nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure le
cas des instituteurs enfin des
professeurs d'écoles qui pouvaient
qui ne pouvait pas partir avant la fin
de l'année scolaire qu'ils avaient
engagé ils ne sont pas les seuls
concernés par ce mécanisme c'est vrai
des contractuels de l'éducation les
maîtres contractuelle c'est vrai des
personnels d'inspection et donc je crois
que cet amendement élargi le champ des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale qui
peuvent être concernés de la même
manière à minimale et mettre contractuel
ça paraît aussi une évidence
merci alors l'avis de la commission sur
ces deux amendements identiques sur
lequel je suis Céline une demande de
scrutin public
merci avis défavorable défavorables
mais ma vie
je vais soumettre scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà nouveau scrutin public qui vous
suivez sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
vous avez compris le principe ce sont
des outils aussi utilisés tout comme le
dépôt d'amendement les explications de
vote et bien pour ralentir la procédure
puisque la gauche s'oppose à la réforme
des retraites et a donc déposé des
amendements pour supprimer alinéa par
les alinéa l'article 7 et ensuite des
scrutin public pour et bien les faire
voter mais elle perd à chaque fois les
arbitrages
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues votre
projet de loi entend par la modification
de l'article
l556-7 du code des pensions civiles et
militaires autoriser les fonctionnaires
dont la limite d'âge est inférieure à 67
ans non plus à un maintien en activité
jusqu'à l'attente d'un toplin mais un
prolongation d'activité ces deux
dispositifs ne relèvent pas de la même
logique le maintien en fonction est en
effet pour les catégories dont la limite
d'âge et inférieur à 67 ans le dernier
recours après épuisement des autres
voies permettant d'arriver à un taux
maximum de cotisations et surtout
destiné à pallier une situation
exceptionnelle destinée en général à
régulariser un dépassement irrégulier la
limite d'âge agent détaché oubliés ou
fin d'année d'enseignement ce maintien
d'ailleurs à corps des temporairement et
sous réserve de l'intérêt de service ce
caractère singulier du maintien en
activité surtout pour les catégories non
syndr
la mettre en parallèle avec le
vieillissement des effectifs signalés
dans le jeûne budgétaire du projet de
loi des finances pour 2022 plus d'un
agent sur trois dans la fonction
publique d'État à plus de 50 ans près de
1 sur 2 en fonction publique
territoriale et il est et il et elle
sont un sur trois dans la fonction
publique hospitalière pourtant en grande
partie plaçant catégorie active en effet
le jaune note que le nombre de
fonctionnaires âgés de 60 ans continue
sa progression plus prononcée en 2019
plus 5,2 qui avait déjà été entamé en
2008 2018 la hausse devrait s'accentuer
les prochaines années par effet
démographique monsieur le ministre
doit-on comprendre que vous souhaitez
normaliser une situation qui devrait
demeurer exceptionnelle mais que vous
allez contraindre à l'habitude et
doit-on comprendre que vous remplacez
une mesure d'exception par une
incitation au travail augmenter de
quelle année je vous remercie
alors la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur défavorable monsieur le
Président
mais ma vie que le rapporteur bien je
vais consulter ceux qui sont favorables
à l'adoption qui vient présente de
l'amendement et à présenter monsieur
Guilman avis contraire
pas adopté et nous allons examiner
quatre amendements
identiques
de 84 rectifié bis madame la Présidente
Nathalie Delacre merci monsieur le
Président c'est abondant à un peu
technique propose en premier lieu
d'intrigue au code général de la
Fonction publique la limite d'âge au
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels en
cohérence avec la codification des
limites d'âge applicable au
fonctionnaires des catégories actives il
est aussi proposé de décaler l'âge à
partir duquel le congé pour raison
opérationnelle peut être pris sur la
base de l'âge de départ anticipé afin de
respecter la durée maximale de cinq
années de ce congé enfin en second lieu
en cohérence avec l'extension du
bénéfice de l'âge de départ anticipé
lorsque le fonctionnaire n'est plus en
catégorie active et avec les mesures
prévues pour les autres corps et cadres
d'emploi cet amendement propose
d'étendre le principe de portabilité à
la bonification de service aux
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels je vous
remercie
merci
l'amendement suivant est un amendement
que présente
oui monsieur le Président il a été
défendu par la présidente de Lattre
c'est vraiment c'est un amendement
identique merci il est défendu
l'amendement
4400 rectifié monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il y a des métiers
idéalisés dans l'imaginaire collectif
notamment celui des pompiers puisqu'ils
sont vus à juste titre comme des héros
prêts à courir tous les dangers pour
sauver nos proches un voisin ou
nous-mêmes malgré le rêve que représente
cette profession notamment chez les plus
jeunes personnes nées dupes sur la
difficulté de ce métier à la fois
physique et psychologique les situations
sont mariées mais souvent difficiles
parce qu'elle touche à l'intime et dans
des conditions souvent dramatiques il
s'agit là d'un critère qui serait déjà
suffisant pour considérer les
sapeurs-pompiers comme appartenant à
cette catégorie dite active
nous invitons donc à voter cet
amendement mais au-delà de cette
pénibilité il y a une autre réalité
celle des besoins et des moyens humains
plus vous dégradez les conditions de
travail et de carrière des pompiers
moins vous parviendrez à recruter et
plus vous mettrez en danger l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et concitoyens après
les déserts médicaux vivre en nous
bientôt dans des airs complets
d'assistance souhaitez-vous que les
pompiers soient aussi âgés que les
personnes qui viennent régulièrement
relever après une chute
n'ajoutons pas de la souffrance à la
justice merci merci alors la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
ces amendements identiques disposition
tout à fait indispensable à vie
favorable à vie favorable monsieur
favorable ce sont des disposition qui
vont dans le sens voulu par les
syndicats notamment qui représentent par
hommes ce Président
[Rires]
Madame
Nathalie Delattre ayant le même
amendement que le mien l'a très bien
défendu donc voilà il est donc à la fois
défendu et soutenu monsieur le ministre
pouvait répondre
avec un avis favorable du Gouvernement
également du ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin nous avons reçu les
organisations syndicales des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires et
professionnels il y a quelques jours
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur ce sont
des dispositions qui vont dans le bon
sens et donc l'amendement porté est
évidemment soutenu
je rappelle que je suis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur ces quatre
amendements monsieur le Président Keller
pour expliquer son vote oui au non mon
groupe monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres nous soutiendrons ses
amendements nous sommes quelques-uns
entre guillemets sénateurs spécialiste
entre guillemets des sapeurs-pompiers
professions que nous défendons sur tous
les bancs de cette émission
et notamment je pense à ce rapport que
nous avons commis sur la protection
physique des sapeurs-pompiers au regard
notamment des agressions qui subissent
très régulièrement et pas uniquement
dans les quartiers prioritaires de de la
ville donc ces amendements vont dans le
bon sens c'est une exception à la règle
que vous voulez imposer à l'ensemble des
Français mais c'est une bonne exception
qui fera l'objet d'un soutien favorable
de notre part bien le scrutin est ouvert
voilà on voit qu'il y a des mesures sur
lesquelles sur certains certains métiers
il va pouvoir y avoir des avancées voter
avec des amendements venus et bien de
sénateurs autre que la commission ou que
effectivement du gouvernement Alexandre
d'une série d'amendements qu'on vient
d'entendre et le temps pour le porter
par Nathalie Delattre une sénatrice
radicale de Gironde sur les
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels et donc
on voit que et bien le gouvernement la
Commission ont donné des avis favorables
que donc il va pouvoir voir des apports
comme cela la part du Sénat pour cette
catégorie socioprofessionnelle
pour de voter
oui
les pompiers font l'unanimité
345 voix pour 0 voix contre voilà
laissez là donc adopté un amendement
qui est le présente Madame
pour ces Monges
alors ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure et
on tient le dire et à le redire depuis
30 ans le travail s'est intensifié pour
toutes les catégories et y compris les
cadres par exemple on va prendre les
cartes parce que c'est là on y pense pas
forcément 2% des cas des exposés à au
moins trois contraintes physiques
en 1984 je parle bien de contraintes
physiques pas des contraintes
temporelles ou sur le sur le
rythme de travail ils sont ils sont
passés de 2 à 26% selon la Grèce même
pour eux le travail est plus intense et
plus pénible et pour les ouvriers bien
entendu c'est pire le nombre d'ouvriers
déclarant subir au moins trois
contraintes de rythme alors qui sont
plutôt des contraintes de cadre était de
8% 8,7 en 84 ils sont aujourd'hui de
53,4%. soit 1 sur 2 ouvriers qui a des
contraintes de rythme par ailleurs 64%
sont exposés à des agents chimiques
dangereux 62% vibrations mécaniques vous
reconnaissez j'espère monsieur le
ministre les pénibilités que vous avez
exclues du CDP face à cela le
gouvernement réagit lors du présent
quinquennat effectivement pour retirer
ces critères de pénibilité jusqu'à vider
le
de son contenu comme le signalait la
Cour des comptes donc c'est cette impact
là sur lequel nous voulons alerter nous
ne pouvons pas voter une réforme des
retraites qui ne parle pas du problème
central celui du travail et celui des
conditions de travail nous ne pouvons
pas voter un texte qui ne tient pas
compte de l'accroissement de la
vulnérabilité des seniors donc qu'ils
vont devoir faire deux ans de plus face
au travail alors même que la réforme de
2010 je le rappelle a fortement augmenté
les arrêts maladie de longue durée des
employés seniors et selon l'adresse le
surcoût est estimé après après d'un
milliard pour un nouveau report à 64 ans
est-ce que c'est surcoût sont estimés
c'est les effets directs induits
indirect dont parlait tout à l'heure mon
collègue est-ce que le projet de loi
contient des dispositions à la hauteur
pour protéger les seniors au travail
merci
alors la vie de la commission Monsieur
Madame la rapporteur général oui merci
monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
alors je ne suis pas sûr qu'en
supprimant l'alinéa 110 chers collègues
et bien vous soyez sur l'objet présenté
tout de suite puisque en fait c'est
alinéa pourrait supprimer des
dispositions maintenant à 68 ans la
limite d'âge applicable au
vice-président du Conseil d'État alors
voilà le dossier du Conseil d'État qui
revient en réalité je pense que vous
n'avez pas choisi le bon alinéa c'est un
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie mais ma vie je vais
consulter ceux qui sont favorables
manifestants devant la main
avis contraire
n'est pas adopté alors deux amendements
qui vont faire ils sont identiques
l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur ferrique
c'est Monsieur Gontard désolé
merci monsieur le Président donc
effectivement il s'agit d'un moment de
suppression de la Liné à 121 à 123
c'est vrai que au-delà justement la
suppression de cet anniv parce que j'ai
bien entendu madame la rapporteur est-ce
qu'elle a pu dire mais je trouve que
sur l'ensemble de ces amendements ce qui
est ce qui est particulièrement
intéressant et la discussion qu'on peut
avoir ce soir même c'est vrai qu'il y a
un petit peu de un petit peu de bois
pourtant je trouve que ça m'est bien en
valeur toutes les problématiques de
cette réforme votre choix de passer de
62 à 64 ans de manière uniforme on voit
bien que quand on liste l'ensemble des
métiers l'ensemble des professions ben
on voit bien qu'il y a des
particularités qu'on est obligé de de
faire de trouver des aménagements en
fonction en fonction des métiers on a pu
d'ailleurs enrichir ce texte au cours de
la soirée puisque des amendements ont
été votés et des amendements de très
partagés d'ailleurs que ça soit pour les
que ça soit pour les égoutiers tout à
l'heure et on a eu un débat important
sur les sportifs sur les instituteurs et
je pense que c'est important à travers
l'ensemble de ces amendements à travers
l'ensemble de ces alinéas de montrer que
oui voilà toute la problématique de
cette de cette réforme de vouloir passer
comme ça donner deux ans de plus à
chacun et quand on regarde on voit bien
que ça ne fonctionne pas que ça ne
marche pas parce que on doit prendre en
compte cette pénibilité on doit prendre
en compte les différentes les
différentes spécificités et donc c'est
tout le sujet de ces différents
amendements et monsieur le ministre
voulait quand même vous remercier parce
que c'est vrai que voilà vous êtes un
peu plus silencieux mais vous êtes assez
intervenu et avec des arguments et qu'au
cours de cette cette soirée et de
l'ensemble de ces de ces différents
amendements on a pu échanger et on a pu
mener je trouve un débat plutôt
intéressant merci alors
madame Cohen présente le monde 4315 X
moi j'aimerais m'arrêter un peu sur la
profession des ingénieurs de contrôle de
la navigation aérienne plus connue
effectivement sous le nom de contrôleur
aérien le trafic aérien s'il n'était pas
là tournerait à la catastrophe ils sont
près de 4000 en France à guider nuit et
jour il y a 1,7 millions de vols par an
et à faire décoller atterrir les avions
en toute sécurité du haut de sa tour de
contrôle aiguilleur du ciel est
contraint de fixer plusieurs écrans et
tablettes 8 à 12 heures d'affilée ce
travail s'opère sous une forte astreinte
cognitive générée par la nécessité d'une
synchronisation temporelle et spatiale
avec le second écuyère aiguilleur et le
centre météo et naturellement le pilote
j'y suis particulièrement sensible ainsi
d'ailleurs que mon collègue Pascal
Savoldelli puisque dans le Val-de-Marne
il y a l'aéroport d'Orly trop souvent la
fatigue dû aux horaires alternés à la
surcharge de travail
donc c'est professionnel à des burn out
un article du Parisien datant du 18
janvier dernier nous apprend que le
ministère des Transports s'est engagé à
ne pas toucher à l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite des contrôleurs du ciel qui
est aujourd'hui de 59 ans pour autant
l'accélération du passage à 43 adminités
pour bénéficier du taux plein mais en
exergue la nécessité de déplafonner la
bonification du cinquième du temps de
service pour ces ingénieurs de contrôle
de la navigation aérienne étant donné
que le bénéfice du complément individuel
temporaire n'est qu'un patch temporaire
basé sur des estimations et n'est jamais
revalorisée dans un contexte où la
question du pouvoir d'achat est brûlante
et qu'il reste encore beaucoup de manque
dans les pensions de retraite de ces
ingénieurs il nous semblait nécessaire
par le biais de cet amendement de repli
d'en faire état et d'exprimer donc nos
soutiens à la mobilisation de certains
syndicats de ce secteur contre cette
réforme des retraites
et d'attirer votre attention sur cette
profession spécifique
merci alors la vie de la commission
madame le rapporteur général voilà il
est 23h26 nous sommes ensemble sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat pour suivre
effectivement ces débats autour de
l'article 7 c'est un cycle sur la mesure
d'âge il reste une dizaine d'amendements
à examiner avant la fin de cet article
pour en parler on va rejoindre notre
journaliste Mathias arez en tribune de
presse dites-nous tout Mathias ou en
sommes-nous dans l'examen de cet article
alors comme vous l'avez dit Quentin il
reste un petit peu moins de 10
amendements à examiner maintenant la
teneur des débats a totalement changé
c'est beaucoup plus cordial on vient
d'ailleurs justement d'entendre le
président Gontard qui a remercié
Stanislas Guérini pour la qualité des
débats qui ont eu lieu ce soir alors
effectivement la gauche a malgré tout
des tricoter les corps de métiers pour
faire durer les débats mais pas pour
toujours pour gagner du temps il y a eu
des débats de fonds comme je viens de le
dire il y a une notamment un vote à
l'unanimité sur le régime
des pompiers ici il y a eu des débats
également sur les égoutiers qui ont été
défendus par Pascal Savoldelli ou encore
la possibilité pour les enseignants de
partir en retraite en cours d'année donc
c'est un rythme de croisière plutôt
rapide effectivement la Commission et le
gouvernement n'interviennent que très
peu et la gauche n'abuse pas de ses
explications de vote peut-être à cause
du coup près de l'article 38 en tout cas
c'est un tout autre débat que ce qu'on a
connu hier soir ici Quentin sans doute
le calme avant la tempête car il est peu
probable que la gauche accepte et bien
que tout se passe tout se passe dans le
calme d'ici à la fin des débats sur
l'article 7 on va sur ça très près
le scrutin est ouvert
mais j'ai pas vu
le scrutin avec l'eau
autant 345 exprimé 343 pour 92 contre
le Sénat n'a pas adopté je vais aborder
deux amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune d'un amendement qui
porte le numéro 30008 qui le présente
Madame Monsieur dessus madame pocemonge
merci monsieur le Président alors nous
nous sommes en train d'achever l'article
7 et c'est vrai que nous essayons de
parler quand même de tous les impacts de
l'article 7 afin d'éclairer le vote
quand même au coeur des discussions
devrait figurer la conséquence devrait
figurer la conséquence des inégalités de
santé au travail et donc la conséquence
de l'allongement de la durée du travail
contenu des inégalités de santé au
travail selon laquelle elle l'enquête
giscope 93 9 patients sur 10 atteints de
concerts ont été exposés à au moins un
cancérogène au cours de sa vie
professionnelle selon le chercheur
Philippe daveziès la grande majorité des
maladies professionnelles reconnues ne
relèvent en effet que de deux chapitres
de pathologies professionnelles les
maladies dues à l'amiante on le sait
avec quel retard et les pathologies de
l'appareil locomoté le commoteur et on
le sait puisqu'ils ne sont pas aussi
dans le lycée de paix de ne pas il donne
pas possibilité de partir en départ
anticipé
les données scientifiques disponibles
permettent d'estimer que 8,5% des
cancers sont d'origine professionnelle
cela représente une fourchette entre
14000 et 30 000 nouveaux cancers
professionnels chaque année or le nombre
total de cancers professionnels reconnus
annuellement est inférieur à 3000
fourchettes 14000 à 30000 et reconnu
3000 ce déficit de reconnaissance des
cancers professionnels cette moindre
reprise en compte notamment de
l'exposition aux agents chimiques
dangereux et aux poussières sont les
principaux responsables des épidémies de
cancer due au travail et sont et alors
que c'est cette exposition les
travailleurs ils sont inégalement
exposés ces 8,5% des cancers sont dus au
travail chez les ouvriers ce sont 20%
des cancers qui sont liés voilà donc il
faut tenir compte de ces inégalités de
santé de l'allongement de la réforme
4317 on quitte l'hémicycle pour quelques
minutes pour bien discuter un instant
avec Nathalie Delattre bonsoir Nathalie
zellâtre vous êtes vice-présidente du
Sénat vous êtes sénatrice du RDSE c'est
ce parti à majorité radicale et vous
êtes élu en Gironde vous avez fait voter
à l'unanimité un amendement c'était il y
a quelques minutes sur l'antenne de
publicain c'était assez rare pour qu'on
se Ciara on s'y arrête puisque curieux
c'est uneanimité autour de votre
amendement sur les pompiers c'est quoi
cet amendement bah écoutez en fait il
s'agit là pour eux
d'être encore des Nations avec ce qui
peut se passer
sur d'autres catégories de
fonctionnaires donc en fait c'est de
pouvoir
davantage que d'autres fonctionnaires
complètement
parce que c'est vrai que
il y a des demandes de cette profession
et au moment de le texte il ne faut pas
les oublier moi j'ai je les ai tellement
côtoyé cet été pendant les enfants dans
mon département effectivement de Gironde
qui a été particulièrement touché que il
est il est juste que nous puissions nous
arrêter sur ce type de profession à
risque et avec un fort engagement donc
voilà il a c'est un amendement qui nous
permet qui était demandé depuis
longtemps par les la Fédération des
sapeurs-pompiers donc voilà on fait
effectivement une mesure de justice Vous
avez réussi à faire à adopter un autre
amendement c'était plutôt dans
l'après-midi celui-ci sur les apprentis
c'est-à-dire de permettre que certains
trimestres achetés puissent être pris en
compte dans les carrières longues si on
a bien compris oui c'est cela alors il y
a eu une série de trois amendements qui
concernait les jeunes les stagiaires et
les apprentis notamment sur leur rachat
de trimestre par exemple pour les
stagiaires ils pouvaient racheter les
jeunes pouvaient racheter d'autres
trimestres de stage
simplement avant dans les deux ans
suivant le stage évidemment quand on a
20 ans qu'on vient de faire un stage à
22 ans c'est très cher et on n'a pas les
moyens de pouvoir acheter les stages les
apprentis il y avait eu des dispositifs
mais qui étaient incomplets c'est à dire
que pour quelques années certains
pouvaient le faire et pas d'autres et
pareil dans des dispositifs ou quand on
est jeune quand on a moins de 30 ans
d'abord un on méconnait et c'est vrai
qu'on
s'interroge peu sur ce que ce sera sa
retraite et ses émoluments à la retraite
sa pension de retraite donc on pense pas
à ce mécanisme de rachat on n'a pas
d'informations sur ce mécanisme de
rachat et puis ceux qui s'y intéressent
ben en fait n'ont pas les fonds parce
que il acheter quand même assez cher
lorsque on a examiné ces amendements que
donc vous avez réussi à faire voter par
une majorité au Sénat on vous a entendu
regretter que ayez à ce moment-là aussi
des débats autour de l'article 38 parce
qu'il a été enclenché autour de vos
amendements et vous a dit c'est dommage
on est en train d'avoir un débat sur le
fond sur l'apprentissage et au final et
bien peut-être que les gens qui nous
écoutent qui sont nombreux ils vont
retenir que c'est passe d'armes entre la
droite et la gauche sur le fait que il y
a une obstruction ou pas on vous a senti
un peu agacé qu'on n'avait pas plus sur
le fond en fait dans ces débats sur la
réforme des retraites c'est ça qui s'est
passé en séance oui c'était surtout
de la part des uns et des autres une
montée en tension en adrénaline on avait
l'impression que
effectivement on oubliait le le texte
l'amendement pour avoir une base d'arme
plus politique et c'est vrai que
je n'avais pas envie que cet amendement
fasse l'objet
d'un règlement de compte politique
alors que effectivement ce sont des
amendements qui sont attendus depuis
longtemps et là aussi qui sont des
amandes de mesure de justice sociale et
important pour ces jeunes
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
retenez vous le se débat effectivement
on voit des moments où il y a ce débat
de fond ou il y a comme ça des échanges
entre la gauche et la droite et le
moment où le débat par en vrille si vous
me permettez l'expression et où on
oublie complètement la réforme des
retraites vous avez cette impression
aussi de faux rythme comme ça sur la
réforme oui tout à fait des moments où
on est vraiment au Sénat et où
effectivement il y a ce débat de fond et
puis après il y a des moments où
effectivement on est rattrapé
par l'instrumentalisation des uns et des
autres
et effectivement c'est dommage parce que
c'est ces moments où effectivement on
est vraiment dans l'esprit Sénat ils
sont très intéressants on a
je pense qu'on est très pédagogue dans
ces moments et que nos concitoyens
peuvent vraiment comprendre
ce qui se joue et se faire et se faire
une idée donc c'est vrai que j'aimerais
qu'on puisse être dans cet esprit c'est
na jusqu'à la fin maintenant
jusqu'à 1h30 du matin puisque on se
voilà on va vers cette échéance
maintenant dans la soirée et on va voir
si on ira au bout de l'article 7 celui
sur la mesure d'âge d'ici à cette
horaire là merci merci
merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est un
amendement qui va satisfaire le
gouvernement et Monsieur le Ministre
irénith puisque l'amendement nous venons
de présenter vous ça se faisait pas
totalement puisqu'il s'adressait qu'à la
fonction hospitalière et celui-là mais
c'est le même et pour tous les
fonctionnaires vous voyez on est là on
est on y a déjà énormément juste dans la
même veine on regrette qu'un certain
nombre d'amendements n'ont pas été jugés
recevable j'entends que monsieur le
rapporteur dit la rooneéo a tourné mais
ce que dit Pascal il a entièrement
raison
c'est qu'on aurait dû débattre
aujourd'hui des nouvelles conditions de
travail et des nouveaux métiers où il y
a beaucoup de pénibilité par exemple un
travail que fait Pascal avec d'autres
sur les livreurs et livreuses on n'avait
pas ça il y a 40 ans mais aujourd'hui
c'est une nouvelle difficulté pour
beaucoup de travailleuses et
travailleurs prenons les entrepôts
Amazon ils s'installe partout dans nos
territoires et souvent ici on a le débat
sur les centres-villes les centres
bourre le commerce qui est tué par ces
grandes entrepôts il y a déjà des études
qui sortent pour les travailleurs et les
travailleuses qui sont dans ces
entrepôts qui ne voient pas le jour
pendant plusieurs heures qui travaillent
à la chaîne c'est des nouvelles
difficultés des nouvelles pénibilités
sauf que comme on n'a pas pu aller au
bout d'un certain nombre d'amendements
sur la question des métiers et c'était
pas pour faire du son stéréo c'était
pour dire que oui il y a beaucoup de
métiers où il y a des difficultés et il
faudra prendre en compte cela notamment
sur leurs conditions de travail leurs
conditions de salaire mais aussi sur des
départs anticipés à la retraite donc
voilà Monsieur Yani vous avez de la
chance on a répondu par l'affirmatif à
votre demande
alors monsieur le rapporteur oui merci
monsieur le Président j'ai l'impression
que son entrepôt d'Amazon de chez vous a
été nationalisé puisque là c'est un
amendement qui concerne les trimestres
cotisées pour les fonctionnaires de
catégorie actifs donc avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre mais la vie
monsieur
demande de scrutin public
voilà c'est un nouveau scrutin public
que nous voyons en ce moment dans
l'hémicycle alors qu'il est 23h40 sur
l'antenne de public c'est là nous sommes
en direct depuis 22h et nous suivons
l'examen de l'article 7 celui sur la
mesure d'âge le report de 62 à 64 ans de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite en
France et on va voir si et bien on va
pas revenir à aller au bout de l'examen
de ce texte ou s'il y a encore des
surprises qui nous attendent à l'image
que c'est joué hier dans la nuit autour
de cet article qui est examiné depuis
maintenant hier 19 heures
alors tu reçois de la salle de presse et
au lieu d'aller
EN 345 exprimé 344 pour 94 contre 250 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté
et nous pensons à l'amendement 3600
3609 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président des alliés
monsieur le rapporteur faut pas éteindre
la ronéo
sur ce ça aurait été peut-être plus
facile si on avait disposé d'une
véritable étude d'impact de cette
réforme et notamment de l'article 7 on
aurait dû le demander au Conseil d'État
en même temps que vous savez la note là
on en reparle donc on aurait eu les deux
notes parce qu'il y a un point aveugle à
cette réforme
on sait que les ouvriers et les employés
qualifiés comme non qualifiés vont être
vraiment les très très grand perdants de
cette réforme et il y a aussi un impact
du coup sur les personnes qui sont le
sur-reprétés dans ces métiers je veux
parler des personnes immigrées
selon l'observateur des inégalités les
postes occupés par les immigrés sont
souvent les emplois qui n'ont pas été
acceptés par les autres du fait des
conditions de travail de rémunération
sécurité nettoyage bâtiment restauration
beaucoup sont des métiers essentiels au
fonctionnement de l'économie et de la
société française
l'étude de la DARES montre que un emploi
sur dix est occupé par un immigré mais
que parmi l'ensemble des 87 familles
professionnelles 35 métiers se
distinguent par une proportion
supérieure et ses professions se sont
celles qui sont exposées à des
conditions de travail contraignantes ou
à des tensions bien sûr sur le marché du
travail des métiers particulièrement
exposés au risque d'accidents du travail
d'épuisement de détérioration de la
santé 35 métiers où les immigrés sont
sur représentés donc qui se
caractérisent par des conditions de
travail plus contraignantes il y a des
contraintes physiques des limitations
physiques des contraintes doriques du
travail répétitif des périodes de
travail durant les journaux ouvrables ou
en dehors des plages de travail habituel
un morcellement des journées de travail
vous avez repéré tous les critères de
pénibilité qui d'ailleurs devrait être
en Russie
c'est fini alors voilà je vous remercie
alors la vidéo monsieur le rapporteur
merci Madame Raymond de possémant je
crois que là vous êtes carrément trompé
de texte dans vos explications de vote
parce que le texte immigration va pas
tarder à venir mais par contre l'objet
de l'abonnement est intéressant puisque
vous proposez de laisser à 62 ans et
surtout pas à 64 ans les les maîtres
d'établissement d'enseignement privé
sous contrat
je ne connaissais pas votre attachement
à l'école privée je la découvre je vous
en félicite donc avis défavorable
[Applaudissements]
je vais consulter
ce qui suive cet amendement le
manifestant devant la main
je sens plus de maîtrise des mains avis
contraire
il n'est pas adopté et nous passons à
l'amendement 3610
madame pensé Monge
c'est celui qui est
défendu il est défendu
il est défendu
invite la Commission
défavorable de la commission de même le
gouvernement je consulte ceux qui sont
favorables manifestants devant la main
avis contraire on n'est pas adopté et
nous passons à
de suppressions
merci j'en profite pour dire à monsieur
le rapporteur que les travailleurs du
privé comme les travailleurs du public
font l'objet de toute notre attention
consulter je voudrais revenir sur un
autre un autre avis sur cette cette
réforme et sur l'article 7 le conseil de
la Caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie qui a émis quand même il
faudrait longtemps un avis défavorable
selon cette caisse une grande loi
autonomie on s'avérait nécessaire on le
sait on nous l'a promise on l'a toujours
pas mais c'est très défavorable pour les
personnes c'est très fort en situation
de handicap et de leurs proches pour les
prochaines années
je reviens pas sur l'accélération du
vieillissement qui est concomitante du
peu de progrès pour prévenir la perte de
d'autonomie car si l'espérance de vie
augmente l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé ne connaît que des évolutions
désormais modestes selon l'INSEE en 2050
pourtant 4 millions de seniors seront en
situation de perte d'autonomie de plus
selon une étude de menée par
l'Observatoire Everest spécialisé dans
l'étude des évolutions et santé au
travail après 60 ans voilà le lien après
60 ans la moitié des ouvriers des
employés doutent que leur état de santé
leur permettent à horizon de deux ans de
poursuivre leur travail actuel quel sera
ce sondage quand on leur demandera d'y
aller d'aller jusqu'à 4 ans de plus et
l'on sait que d'autres travaux
scientifiques par ces confirme ses
doutes ils sont fondés il laisse
présager la survenue d'incapacité dans
son avis motivé donc le Conseil souhaite
alerter sur l'impact potentiel d'un
allongement de la durée du travail sur
l'équilibre des eaux de branches en
particulier pour les professions
présentant un niveau élevé de pénibilité
si cette dernière n'était insuffisamment
prise en compte
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
alors l'avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur
je vous sens impatiente de parler de
santé au travail c'est l'article 9 j'ai
pas l'impression qu'à travers ses
amendements vous soyez vraiment
réellement pressé d'y arriver c'est un
moment concerne lui et le remboursement
des trimestres rachetés comme vous
l'avez bien compris dans les
explications de vote donc avis
défavorable merci la vie de gouvernement
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
Président oui il se trouve je crois
madame la sénatrice que vous avez voté
avec tout le monde le fait de faciliter
le rachat des trimestres pour
l'apprentissage pour les stages pour les
études si on a d'autres potentiellement
plus personne ne peut racheter trimestre
puisque vous supprimez le dispositif de
rachat
avis des favorable
il est retiré
à 3614 monsieur dessus oui merci
monsieur le Président on arrive à la fin
de cet article 7
parmi les défenseurs de cette réforme on
a pu lire le soutien d'Elon musk au
départ moi je me suis mis un peu
interrogé pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'il en
avait à faire de de cette réforme et
puis en fait on comprend assez vite
puisqu'elle correspond assez bien à sa
vision du monde puisque avec cette
réforme évidemment les inégalités déjà
criante vont s'aggraver
quelques seniors multimillionnaires et
tant d'autres sans emploi et sans
retraite plusieurs grands patrons du CAC
40 ont repris leur retraite ces derniers
mois ils ont tous cédé les reines alors
de leur entreprise en 2021 ou 2022 ainsi
que la direction opérationnelle de leur
groupe tout en restant au moins
provisoirement président du Conseil
administration c'est néo retraités ont
eu la liberté de choisir quand il
partira à la retraite dans quelles
conditions et par qui il serait remplacé
en parallèle la présenterait forme des
retraites va maintenir des milliers de
personnes supplémentaires dans le sas de
précarité sans emploi ni retraite
l'adresse relever en 2020 que le taux de
pauvreté des personnes ni en emploi ni
en retraite de 53 à 69 ans était de 32%
de plus en 2018 le taux de pauvreté des
personnes de 65 ans ou plus or personne
vivant en institution était de 8,6% plus
d'un million de personnes pauvres cette
réforme va aggraver ces inégalités il
faut la retirer je vous remercie
merci
avis de la commission
[Musique]
merci sont des dispositions très
intéressantes madame poncemont je
puisque vous parlez de
la prise en compte des
temps de travail acquis et qui
pourraient être ensuite redéplacé
quand vous avez une titularisation c'est
dommage de vouloir supprimer cela
c'était une avancée sociale tout à fait
significative vous nous proposez de la
supprimer en vous comprenez qu'on donne
un avis défavorable
alors je suis le ministre le même avis
défavorable ce qui sont favorables
manifestants en levant la main
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté une pension
d'amendement 3615
qui le présente
il est défendu
je consulte ceux qui sont alors l'avis
de la commission pardonnez-moi
vaut mieux le retirer celui-là celui-là
aussi monsieur le Président vaut mieux
le retirer vous souhaitez un retrait
il est retiré
le 3617 madame ponce à Madame Vogel
merci monsieur le Président on arrive
donc là maintenant véritablement à la
fin de l'article 7 et je voudrais en
profiter pour appeler quelques
informations selon le rapport sur les
objectifs de la réforme remis par le
gouvernement le déficit serait de 12
milliards d'euros en 2027 et de 13,5
milliards en 2030 la fatalité présumée
de ce déficit dont le corps estime qu'il
ne provient pas d'une dérive des
dépenses conduit des autorités à
prescrire un report de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits à la retraite à 64 ans et une
accélération du calendrier de la réforme
Touraine pourtant selon le corps
lui-même le problème du système des
retraites provient du fait de
l'insuffisance de la trajectoire des
ressources un ensemble de mesures plus
juste moins brutal ont été présentés
pour financer différemment notre système
de retraite augmenter le nombre de
fonctionnaires
augmenter les cotisations selon le corps
une augmentation de 0,8 points de
cotisation d'ici 2027 suffirait à elle
seule à combler le déficit attendu cela
correspondrait à 28 euros par mois pour
le salaire moyen sachant que selon le
corps le salaire moyen devrait augmenter
de 128 euros d'ici 2027
l'augmentation du taux de cotisation
salariale et possible sans impacter le
pouvoir d'achat on peut aussi augmenter
les salaires ce qui augmente
automatiquement les cotisations sociales
on peut en finir avec les politiques
d'exonération
inutiles et inefficace
on peut aussi revoir le calendrier de
remboursement de la CADES vous avez
refusé l'intégralité de ces mesures
néanmoins ce sont les seuls qui
permettraient de financer notre système
des retraites de façon juste efficace
sans faire trimer les plus précaires
deux ans de plus vous allez me dire
monsieur le ministre ça n'a rien à voir
avec la Linéa que vous supprimez en
l'occurrence c'est pas vraiment le cas
puisque c'est le dernier alinéa qui
stipule quand l'article va s'appliquer
nous souhaiterions que cet article ne
s'applique jamais
monsieur le rapporteur
merci merci c'était tout à fait ça vous
souhaitez effectivement décaler cette
réforme donc il y aurait plus d'impact
sur 2023 et en conséquence dans le cadre
de ce PLFSS ce serait
anticonstitutionnel vous avez retrouvé
votre finesse d'esprit pour proposer un
amendement que bien sûr avis défavorable
le ministre même avis je consulte ceux
qui sont favorables le manifestant
devant là-bas
à vie contraire
il n'est pas adopté
je voudrais informer
le Sénat que l'amendement déposé par
notre collègue Jean-Marie Warner
Anderson numéro
2334 a été retiré
en conséquence
les amendements numéro
4865 tombe
[Applaudissements]
nous allons donc passer au vote sur
l'article 7
je vous indique d'ores et déjà que j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe CRCE
en application de l'article 42 alinéa 10
de notre règlement il conformément la
décision de la Conférence des Présidents
lors de sa réunion de ce mercredi 8 mars
je vous rappelle que les prises de
parole explication de vote sur chaque
article de ce projet de loi sont limités
à un seul orateur par groupe politique
et un seul sénateur
ne figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
pour une durée de 2 minutes je vais donc
donner la parole à un orateur par groupe
madame j'ai vu madame la Présidente
assassin levé la main
merci monsieur le Président donc la
droite sénatoriale la majorité du Sénat
avec la complicité du gouvernement a
perdu son sang-froid comme je l'ai dit
hier soir sur cet article 7 ensemble
vous ne supportez plus l'exercice
pleinement constitutionnel du droit
d'amendement de sous-amendements et de
l'expression des parlementaires pour sa
part la droite sénatoriale menée par
Monsieur Retailleau nouveau ministre
chargé des Relations avec le Parlement
et madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales et les rapporteurs
ont violé le règlement du Sénat en
déclarant irrecevable des abonnements
qui étaient pourtant pleinement sur cet
article 7
toutes toutes les procédures possibles
et imaginables ont été dégainées par
plusieurs présidents de groupe
favorables à cet article 7 sais-je le
redis la démonstration d'un coup de
force monsieur le Président vous vous
êtes assis sur votre propre règlement et
la prétendue sagesse du Sénat on a pris
un coup c'est une ligne rouge qui a été
franchie elle porte gravement atteinte
aux principes constitutionnels de clarté
et de sincérité des débats votre
objectif c'est de s'assurer l'opposition
à ce projet d'allongement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 74 à 64 ans au
cœur de l'article 7 vous avez agi de la
sorte soir même d'une magnifique
mobilisation du peuple qui ne veut pas
subir deux années de travail
supplémentaire avec le gouvernement vous
tentez d'imposer ce dogme libéral celui
qui prend toujours plus au plus pauvre
pour donner toujours plus au plus riche
avec vos procédures vous avez empêché la
discussion de nos propositions
celle qui vise à renforcer la
participation des revenus les plus aisés
et financiers au financement du régime
de retraite vous n'avez pas voulu
protégeant actionnaires et patronat de
ce débat essentiel sur le partage des
richesses vous battez le débat pour
dissimuler la vérité à nos concitoyens
parmi lesquels vos propres électeurs qui
sont aussi dans la mobilisation à votre
grande âme évidemment monsieur le
Président nous voterons nous voterons
pour cet article 7
issu de la corselée entre le
gouvernement et la majorité de droite
sénatoriale
Monsieur Olivier Hainaut
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres
majoritairement et sans surprise nous
voterons cet article 7 nous ovotons
cette article 7 et les rapporteurs tout
au long de ce débat l'ont démontré parce
que nous avons la conviction que nous
sauvons le système de retraite par
répartition nous lui donnons un avenir
mes chers collègues oui c'est bien ça
que nous faisons
nous votons cette article 7 parce que
nous pensons et c'est un clivage entre
nous que nous avons la responsabilité
oui la responsabilité d'aller au bout de
ce texte nous avons cette responsabilité
par rapport au système par répartition
mais nous avons aussi cette
responsabilité par rapport et je vous
réponds par rapport à la crédibilité et
l'image du Sénat par rapport à la
crédibilité et l'image de la démocratie
représentative car que deviendrait la
démocratie représentative si ni
l'assemblée est ni le Sénat ne se
prononcer sur un texte aussi essentiel
un dernier mot
sur les arguments
vous avez travaillé je dirais même que
si c'était à la quantité de salive et
d'encre il faudrait donner le maillot
jaune à Madame ponce
j'ai tout entendu deux ans fermes comme
si le travail était une prison mais que
quelle vision triste de la société voler
deux ans
mais en même temps voyez-vous je pense
que je n'arrive pas à croire notamment
ceux qui ont voté la réforme Touraine
que il y ait beaucoup de sincérité dans
vos arguments vous découvrez que le
système de retraite est parfois injuste
mais pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas
découvert lorsque vous abordiez la
réforme Touraine bon sang et puis je
vais finir comme j'en ai l'habitude par
deux citations au fond c'est vos
intérêts électoraux que vous dépendez
l'hypocrisie c'était Balzac qui disait
ça l'hypocrisie n'est rien de plus qu'un
hommage à l'intérêt vos intérêts
électoraux et donc nous nous le
choisissons pas l'hypocrisie nous
choisissons la responsabilité la
responsabilité c'est le prix à payer du
succès disait Churchill je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame Lubin
mes chers collègues nous venons de
passer d'une minute de quelques secondes
la date du 8 mars l'histoire retiendra à
Monsieur du soft
que votre nom et votre nom monsieur du
monsieur le ministre du socle restera à
jamais attaché restera à jamais attaché
à celui d'une réforme qui fera revenir
presque
40 ans en arrière
oui oui presque 40 ans en arrière et
franchement j'espère quand votre fort
intérieur ça vous parle et ça ne vous
fait pas particulièrement plaisir et
surtout l'histoire on retiendra quand
celui mars 2023 nous aurons nous aurons
voté vous aurez voté un projet de loi
qui fera travailler les salariés les
plus modestes ceux qui travaillent déjà
depuis longtemps ceux qui ont les
salaires les plus modestes ceux qui ont
les emplois les plug difficile et dans
lesquels nous trouvons une grande
majorité de femmes
l'histoire retiendra que c'est quasiment
un 8 mars que vous aurez fait voter ce
texte là alors non nous ne sommes pas
des irresponsables non nous ne sommes
pas des irresponsables le rapport du
corps nous le connaissons nous sommes
quelques-uns ici à le connaître bien
plus que vous tous ici rassembler pour
l'instant pour l'instant à ce jour à ce
jour à ce jour il n'y a pas de déficit
et oui il y a des projections qui
donnent peut-être peut-être un déficit
de 13 milliards d'euros sur
360 milliards d'euros de retraite qui
sont payés tous les ans alors oui alors
oui nous disons nous disons qu'il faut
effectivement
s'intéresser à l'avenir de nos retraites
mais nous avons développé aussi qu'il y
avait tout un tas d'autres solutions
histoire retiendra que vous vous faites
payer les ouvriers les salariés les gens
les plus modestes de ce pays
monsieur lévrier pour le gros père des
pays
merci monsieur le Président le constat
du corps éclaire nous devions le prendre
à bras le corps le déficit structurel de
notre système de retraite existe et sur
le long terme et très terriblement
dangereux pour notre système et pour la
protection des retraités oui l'article 7
demande un effort aux Français il n'est
pas question de le nier oui cet effort
est indispensable et il est
indispensable en particulier pour les
jeunes et je suis très étonné que dans
cette hémistique nous ayons quasiment
jamais aborder les jeunes je regrette
aussi toujours que les gens qui sont à
ma droite et ce besoin systématique de
parler quand les autres ont la parole
c'est assez pénible et cet effort est
vraiment et moi je veux parler à un
autre jeunesse et leur dire qu'à travers
cet effort que nous demandons à tous
c'est pour eux que nous le faisons pour
que dans 30 ans quand ils seront un peu
moins jeunes ils se disent oui notre
système de retraite fonctionne oui le
système par répartition est un système
fort qui nous protège et qui protégera
plus tard les la jeunesse je me réjouis
que ce vote permette aussi le débat qui
a lu et permettre surtout de continuer
le travail sur les articles qui vont
arriver et qui sont les articles vous
les avez tous mis vous êtes
extraordinaire
cet article les articles suivants qui
sont les articles qui protègent qui
protègent je le redis et en particulier
les plus fragiles enfin je voudrais
rappeler que nous sommes le Parlement
que nous représentons les Français et
qu'il est de notre devoir de voter
l'ensemble de ce texte nous sommes
attendus sur ce sujet et nous devons
être à la hauteur je vous remercie
d'inscrire monsieur le Président
Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
3 3 remarques
trois remarques
en guise explications de vote la
première une nouvelle preuve ce soir une
nouvelle preuve d'obstruction les 90
sous amendements de Madame Hubin qui
décale d'une journée la remise d'un
rapport ça n'est pas mesdames messieurs
de l'obstruction vous êtes en train de
vous
mélangez jamais nous accepterons que
vous mélangiez le Sénat l'obstruction ça
n'est pas la démocratie parlementaire
c'est le Parlement qui se fait Hara-Kiri
c'est un 49,3 à l'envers la deuxième
observation
c'est l'hypocrisie les donneurs de
leçons vous qui n'avez pas à brochet
vous qui n'est pas abrogé justement le
décalage d'âge de 2010 vous l'avez
empiré avec la loi Touraine 43 à nuités
aujourd'hui c'est 65 ans c'est là la
réalité et ça il faut le dire aux
Français et enfin bien sûr que nous
allons bien sûr nous allons voter cet
article 7 vous espériez qu'on ne le vote
pas ce soir nous le voterons ce soir
vous le voterons parce que il va
permettre de sauver le régime de
retraite par répartition bien sûr bien
sûr c'est un levier budgétaire mais ceux
qui se moquent des chiffres se moque des
gens derrière les chiffres il y a les
déficits derrière les défis visites il y
a l'argent des Français derrière
l'argent des Français il y a la peine
des Français et puis et puis la limite
d'âge justement est protectrice relisez
la fameuse étude de la CNAV elle avait
comment dirais-je comparer une
simulation deux hypothèses première
hypothèse uniquement repousser les
invités 300 euros en moins de retraites
par an elle avait comparé l'autre
hypothèse un relèvement justement de la
durée légale le gain c'était 300 euros
en moyenne et bien vous savez cette
bande d'âge est protectrice c'est un
filet de sécurité et nous le voterons
dès ce soir
d'autres demandes de groupe voilà pour
ces manches
merci monsieur le Président moi je suis
désolé quand même que vous nous
contraignez à une seule personne parce
qu'il y a un impact dont on n'a pas
parlé c'est l'impact sur les inégalités
territoriales les manifestations elles
ont été exceptionnelles aussi dans le
monde rural vous devriez le savoir moi
ce que je souhaiterais dire un petit peu
c'est que vous connaissez les effets de
la réforme de 2010 vous les connaissez
ce sera les mêmes aggravé pour la
réforme que vous vous apprêtez à voter
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que
l'article 7 c'est l'article dont le
gouvernement dit qu'il est non
négociable c'est le seul article que
vous voulez effectivement que les
syndicats voulaient qu'on discute et
longuement hier il nous restait cinq
jours vous avez sabré se disait cet
article donc ne vous réclamez pas des
syndicats pour ce qui est de 2010 on les
connaît les effets l'effet dominant de
la réforme a été de figer des situations
atteintes à l'approche de la soixantaine
dans l'atteinte d'un nouvel âge c'est le
fameux justement de deux ans du
précarité c'est chez les ouvriers la
hausse de la précarité on vous l'a dit
pour les femmes nous en avons parlé
c'est la durée de la retraite qui a
diminué d'un an et qui va diminuer
encore de plus d'un an car ce n'est plus
l'allongement ce n'est plus permis par
la longement de la durée de vie on ne
travaille pas plus longtemps parce qu'on
vit plus longtemps vous allez nous faire
travailler plus longtemps parce qu'on va
rester moins longtemps à la retraite
c'est une augmentation on l'a dit des
personnes au minima et surtout c'est un
effet c'est un une atténuation de
l'effet de l'effet redistributif de la
retraite les effets les effets ont été
anti-redismutifs et ils vont l'être un
peu plus donc oui voilà les
enseignements 2010 nous disent que cette
réforme est injustifiée elle est
inégalitaire elle est productiviste et
nous en reparlerons et c'est pour ça
messieurs qu'elle est impopulaire et
c'est pour ça que il suffira pas de la
voter
les le mouvement social continuera
jusqu'à son retrait
es et maintenant de groupes je vais
maintenant passer au scrutin public
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 sur l'ensemble de l'article 7
le scrutin est ouvert
il est minuit passé de 9 minutes nous
sommes en direct sur public c'est pour
suivre ce scrutin public sur l'ensemble
de l'article 7 mesures phare mesure
centrale du projet de loi de réforme des
retraites voulu par l'exécutif une
accélération ces dernières minutes pour
arriver au vote sur l'ensemble de ce
texte et sans surprise la majorité de la
droite et du centre qui devrait adopter
cette mesure dans les prochaines minutes
et aussi donc une défaite pour la gauche
sénatoriale qui aura tenté des dépôts
d'amendement des explications de vote ou
encore des scrutins publiques pour
ralentir cette échéance mais la droite
qui va réussir à parvenir à faire voter
cette mesure dans les prochaines minutes
inscrite un public donc on va voir
l'ensemble de la cartographie du vote à
l'échelle de l'hémicycle on va pouvoir
voir s'il y a par exemple des sénateurs
LR ou centrist qui manquent à l'appel
dans ce scrutin solennel de l'ensemble
de l'hémicycle on va voir sans surprise
en revanche que elle est 90 sénateurs de
gauche vont voter contre cet donc le 7
article c'est un don qui décale de 62 à
64 ans l'âge de départ à la retraite et
qui accélère la réforme Touraine
effectivement et les 43 annuités vous
êtes en train de vivre ce vote en direct
sur public Sénart on va écouter Gérard
lacher prononcer les résultats de ce
scrutin public
316 pour 201 contre 115 le Sénat a
adopté l'article 7
[Applaudissements]
nous allons passer après l'article 7 un
des articles additionnels avec tout
d'abord cet amendements
identiques
un amendement présenté 136
qui le présente
monsieur Burgoa
défendu
un amendement 226 rectifiés monsieur
Dupont il est défendu
il n'est pas dépendu un amendement
présenté par Monsieur sol 238 rectifié
n'est pas défendu madame la un
amendement présenté par
madame Delattre
n'est pas défendu un amendement présenté
par le président kaner je vais le
défendre monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur les ministres c'est
un amendement qui concerne les
directeurs départementaux qui sont très
précieux vous le savez au sein des
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels ils
dirigent les corps des sapeurs-pompiers
sur le plan technique administratif
opérationnel ce sont aussi les
partenaires privilégiés des préfets qui
sont de fait leur patron cet amendement
vise à ce que nos combattants du feu
quel que soit l'emploi qu'ils occupent
peut-être classés comme catégorie active
car le caractère dangereux de ce métier
des missions qui sont assignées à ces
agents publics et reconnus par la
sécurité civile vous le savez les
pompiers partenaires de cette sécurité
civile font face à de nouveaux enjeux et
notamment y compris le réchauffement
climatique et je voudrais à nouveau
comme nous l'avons fait à plusieurs
reprises cet été salués leur
extraordinaire leur extraordinaire
engagement notamment dans les feux de
Gironde pour cela nous avons besoin de
recrutement nous avons besoin de
susciter des vocations mes chers
collègues et donc nous avons besoin de
fidéliser or il dispose d'un régime
favorable s'il dispose il est minuit 12
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat vous
devenez de le suivre en direct sur notre
chaîne le Sénat vient d'adopter
l'article 7 mesures phare du projet de
loi de réforme des retraites pour en
parler on va rejoindre tout de suite
Mathias ares qui a suivi ce vote depuis
la tribune de presse et le vote est net
Mathias
merci
201 pour 115 contre mais si vous me le
permettez Quentin je souhaiterais
revenir sur comment les choses se sont
accélérées là dans la dernière demeure
et bien nous étions entre un analyser
les amendements à cet article 7 et c'est
donc l'article du centre triste
l'amendement pardon du centriste
Jean-Marie
Vandenberg qui a décidé de retirer cet
amendement auquel était accolé plus de
90 sous amendements des socialistes le
fait de retirer cet amendement a fait
tomber c'est sous amendements nous
sommes donc arrivés au moment du vote
sur le sur la totalité de cet article 7
et c'est à ce moment-là donc le
président Gérard lâcher a décidé
d'activer l'article 42 à linena 10 du
Règlement du Sénat un article qui permet
simplement une prise de parole par un
groupe ici dans l'hémicycle ce sont donc
Eliana Sassi Monique Lubin Raymond de
penser a pris la parole pour la gauche
qui ont donc critiqué une manœuvre
politique de la part de la magie de la
majorité sanatoriale de complicité ils
ont accusé de complicité avec le
gouvernement c'est également Bruno
Retailleau qui a pris la parole qui a
dit que les LR que les la gauche était
en train de se mélanger et que le
Parlement se faisait haracheri nous
sommes ensuite passé au vote du scrutin
avec les résultats que je vous ai donné
Quentin je voulais redonne 200 pour 115
contre merci Mathias merci pour ce récit
autour de ce vote qui vient d'avoir lieu
dans les mysticles du Sénat pourra en
parler j'accueille ici Bruno Retailleau
bonsoir Monsieur le taillot vous êtes le
chef de fil le président du groupe LR
ici au Sénat en mode réaction pour 2001
contre 115 le Sénat a adopté l'article 7
et adopter très largement on s'est
battus parce que la gauche a multiplié
les manœuvres les manœuvres dilatoires
des manœuvres d'obstruction vous avez
commencé l'examen hier exactement j'ai
dénoncé ce soir par exemple des
pendant cinq jours cinq nuits on a
écouté patiemment et en réalité le
contrat n'a pas été si j'ose dire honoré
puisque il fallait non seulement aller
le 7 mars pour voter le 7 mais dès
qu'elle est le plus possible et on s'est
aperçu que en réalité il ne voulait rien
voter du tout donc le Sénat à adopter
l'article 7 est-ce que vous le dites
vous offrez une bouffée d'oxygène à
Elisabeth borne et à son gouvernement ce
soir moi je m'en fiche moi c'est très
fort vous savez bien qu'elle est née ici
on la vote depuis 4 ans tous les ans ici
ma boussole c'est pas Madame board ma
boussole moi c'est les Français je veux
que on sache ce soir qu'en 2030 quand
cette réforme va s'appliquer la France
sera le seul pays d'Europe ou en partira
à 64 ans ou on aura sans doute le
meilleur de tous les pays d'Europe le
meilleur régime de retraite notamment et
de prise en compte des carrières longues
c'est ça la vérité et qu'est-ce que vous
dites à vos électeurs qui peut-être se
disent que vous êtes la béquille de la
macronie ce soir
je me fiche pour moi l'intérêt général
c'est ce qui surplombe tout je n'ai pas
tendu madame borne ou email Macron pour
voter ce type de mesure puisque ça fait
quatre ans qu'on les vote simplement
expliquez-moi et la gauche nous l'a pas
expliqué comment faire pour combler un
déficit de plus de 150 milliards d'euros
qui fera exploser le système de retraite
à très court terme 150 milliards d'euros
dans les 10 ans expliquez-moi comment
est-ce qu'on compense la démographie
c'est à dire on a toujours plus de
retraités et il faut payer les pensions
et toujours moins de cotisants alors
comment on fait alors encore une
dernière question c'est sur la suite du
texte maintenant et bien il va y avoir
une course jusqu'au au dimanche soir à
minuit pour finir l'examen des 20
articles et quid de la suite j'ai envie
de vous poser comme question et
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ensuite il va
y avoir comme ça une recherche de
compromis avec les députés également
écoutez après vous les dire après le
dimanche si je comprends bien le 15
c'est à dire mercredi prochain et il
sera une commission
c'est député sénateurs
un compromis je ne doute pas qu'on
trouve un compromis mais attendez là
vous anticipez un petit peu on n'est pas
encore à la CMP on est à la l'étape la
deuxième étape il y a eu le fiasco il y
a eu le fiasco de l'Assemblée nationale
et aujourd'hui le Sénat relève l'image
du Parlement sauf si la gauche sans tête
à faire de l'instruction parce que ça ça
va abîmer et j'en appelle mes collègues
de gauche que je connais bien et qui en
général sont respectueux du débat
parlementaire et démocratique nabiment
pas ce qui nous reste comme institution
parlementaire en France parce que sinon
c'est la porte ouverte à l'anti
parlementarisme et je pense que la
démocratie elle aussi sera abîmée j'ai
une toute dernière question si vous me
le permettez qu'est-ce que vous dites à
l'Inter syndical ils ont mobilisé des
centaines peut-être des millions de
personnes dans les rues 6 fois d'affilée
et ce sera peut-être qu'il regarde
Public Sénat il voit le vote de cette
mesure dont ils ne veulent pas c'est à
dire l'Inter syndicale la totalité des
des syndicats en France qu'est-ce que
vous leur répondez mais le droit de
grève c'est un droit qui est constituait
le même en reconnu ce que je voudrais
leur dire c'est que ils ont le droit de
manifester bien sûr mais surtout bravo
parce qu'ils ont manifesté dans l'ordre
et quand je vois les débats à
l'Assemblée nationale le désordre était
à l'Assemblée nationale l'ordre était
dans la rue
et bien merci merci beaucoup Bruno
Retailleau pour cette réaction que vous
avez accordé en priorité à publique
Sénat on va aller rejoindre Mathias Arès
dans l'hémicycle Mathias qui va nous
faire le récit de ce qui s'est joué ces
dernières minutes dans l'hémicyclin et
bien écoutez Quentin c'est le
l'amendement le dernier abonnement qui
devait être analysé ici dans l'hémicycle
il était porté par le centriste
Jean-Marie vanlenberg et bien il est cet
amendement était un couplé de plus de 90
sous amendements de la part de la gauche
ce qui devait prolonger les débats et
bien le centriste a tout simplement
décidé de le retirer ce qu'a fait tomber
tous les samement les sous amendements
qui étaient accolés on arrivait donc au
vote il allait avoir plusieurs
explications de vote mais c'est un
article du règlement le 42 10 qui a
accéléré les débats et qui a donc permis
une seule prise de parole avant de
passer au scrutin scrutin qui vous le
savez a été largement remporté par le
pour 201 votes pour donc reporter à la
mesure d'âge de 62 à 64 ans et 115
contre Quentin merci Mathias pour toutes
ces explications depuis la tribune de
presse de l'hémistique j'accueille sur
ce plateau Olivier du stop bonsoir
monsieur le ministre vous êtes ministre
du Travail de du plein emploi et de
l'insertion une réaction à ce qui vient
de se jouer c'était il y a 10 minutes
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat et le Sénat
qui adopte 210 voix pour 115 contre une
réaction c'est d'abord une étape de
franchi c'est une étape importante avec
un article majeur puisque c'est
l'article qui me relève l'âge de départ
qui leur relève progressivement en
tenant compte de la pénibilité en tenant
compte des carrières longues avec des
mesures d'accompagnement comme jamais il
n'en a été mise en place mais c'est cet
article qui par son adoption permet à la
fois de garantir l'équilibre financier
du système et le financement des mesures
nouvelles autour justement de la
précarité ou du relèvement du minimum de
pension quid de ce débat qu'on a eu
depuis hier 19h on a commencé l'examen
de sortie que le 7 qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez sur le fond il y a eu à la fois
une polémique sur les amendements qui
tombent des vocifération dans
l'hémistique des deux côtés de
l'hémicycle on n'a pas le sentiment
forcément que le débat était extrêmement
sain ni
sereinte qu'on n'a pas pu aller au fond
non plus forcément je crois que vous
allez au fond nous sommes allés au fond
nous avons discuté de fond nous avons
discuté dangereux extrêmement important
et c'est une grande différence
malheureusement si je puis dire avec le
débat tel qui sait dérouler à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'Assemblée
nationale seul les deux premiers
articles ont été examinés et non pas
aller jusqu'à là nous en sommes à
l'article 7 et nous allons continuer à
débattre avec l'espoir pour le
gouvernement que nous puissions débattre
de tous les articles du texte d'ici à
dimanche soir et c'est un point qui est
important c'est une différence qui est
majeure nous sommes heureux n'est pas le
mot mais satisfait que cette étape soit
franchie au Sénat est-ce que vous dites
merci à la majorité de la droite et du
centre vous qui parliez d'une réforme de
gauche avec 200 une voix pour
essentiellement les voix DL et je dis
merci à tous les sénateurs qui ont à la
fois participé au débat de la droite et
de santé qui ont de la droite et du sang
du Rassemblement démocratique social et
européen de liberté et territoire de la
majorité présidentielle mais aussi les
sénateurs de la majorité sénates
sénatoriale centriste et de droite mais
est-ce que le vote que l'on vient
d'avoir dans les musiques ne démontre
pas que c'est une réforme qui est
plébiscité par la droite elle-même se
revendique la paternité de mesure c'est
une réforme nécessaire pour équilibrer
notre système de retraite et comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire dans quand on
regarde autour de nous quand on regarde
ce qui se passe en Europe cette réforme
elle aurait pu être mise en place par
n'importe quelle gouvernement
social-démocrate en Europe tout autour
de nous libéraux socio-démocrate les
gouvernements tous augmenté l'âge de
départ pour équilibrer le système la
grande différence c'est que nous mettons
en oeuvre en place pardon des mesures
d'accompagnement social très fortes j'ai
une dernière question si vous le voulez
bien ce vote intervient au lendemain de
la sixième mobilisation en France et
avec des centaines de cortèges dans de
nombreuses villes et qu'est-ce que ça
donne comme image le Parlement qui vote
une mesure et de nombreux Français il y
a mobilisent pour la dénoncer il y a
deux choses qu'il faut dire d'abord il y
a plusieurs temps la démocratie et il
n'y a pas de conflit légitimité le
mouvement social est légitimité le
Parlement a une légitimité qui est de
voter la loi et quand je dis qu'il y a
de temps parce qu'il y a une
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales patronales ça n'a pas suffi
pour surmonter tous les désaccords nous
le savons aujourd'hui il y a un temps du
Parlement mais après l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le Sénat et c'est le
rythme la scansion logique des choses et
bien merci merci à vous merci Olivier du
soft d'avoir pris le temps de venir au
micro depuis lixenna pour cette réaction
alors que je vous le rappelle je vous le
rappelle si vous nous rejoignez à minuit
24 en direct sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat et il y a quelques minutes le
Sénat à adopté 200 une voix pour 115
contre l'article 7 celui sur la mesure
d'âge dans la réforme des retraites
alors que le texte avait été commencé
d'être examiné des hier et que de
nombreux incidents avaient émaillé la
séance pour en parler j'accueille ici
Pascal Savoldelli bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur communiste une réaction à
ce vote est-ce que c'est une une
déception pour la gauche Sénat oriale la
question c'est pas une déception pour la
gauche d'abord vous savez on a entendu
beaucoup l'histoire de de l'obstruction
je viens de voir le résultat du vote
115 parlementaires sénateurs et
sénatrices ont voté contre c'est au-delà
des rangs de la gauche
de remplacement donc il n'y a pas eu
d'obstruction de la part de la gauche
c'est environ 25 voix de plus que ce que
vous aviez sur les autres scrutins
publics depuis le début de l'examen oui
en effet c'est juste et vous avez pu
observer comme moi qui a eu 22 sénateurs
qui se sont obtenus effectivement sur
300 à 45 voix seuls 3016 ont été
exprimées et qu'est-ce que ça dit au
lendemain d'une grande mobilisation avec
l'intersyndicale au complet qui dénonce
cette réforme que la droite et le centre
face voter ce texte qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque vous cette
différence complète entre les les deux
mondes non mais là on a une distorsion
sur les distorsions entre le régime
politique
et la démocratie sociale mais du coup
entendre le Parlement maintenant non
mais c'est pas une question seulement
attendez je vais essayer de répondre à
votre question je vous laisse mais on a
assisté quand même à une corrédaction
entre la majorité c'est nota la
gouvernement d'une refonte de l'article
où on va avec ça on va on va vers quel
régime vous voyez ça veut dire que qui
est trop qu'il faut changer l'opposition
la vie majoritaire des Français des
Françaises
donc on est innovant une épreuve
démocratique l'ensemble donc quand vous
me demandez ce qu'il faut écouter
l'intersyndicale
c'est une évidence qu'il faut écouter
l'Inter syndical et l'Inter syndicale
elle a sa valeur de représentativité du
monde du travail mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de femmes
d'hommes de jeunes qui sont pas
forcément engagés syndicalement qui ne
veulent pas travailler deux années de
plus et là ce que vient de faire la
droite c'est qu'à la fois elle vient
d'encourager la réforme Touraine
et deuxièmement de ne rien amander rien
n'a mangé qui contrarie la politique du
gouvernement entre à la fois
l'allongement de deux ans et à la fois
la question des annuités et excusez-moi
du problème le problème il est simple
c'est que il y a aucun effort demandé
de regarder les débats que nous avons eu
sur les super profits sur voilà il y a
l’argent de Vaca l'argent il y a pas
d'efforts de ce point de vue là on avait
entendu que la gauche avait accepté
l'idée qu'il y ait un vote sur l'article
7 que qui était derrière une demande un
syndicale et aussi parce que peut-être
vous misiez sur davantage de division à
droite et au centre c'est aussi l'un des
l'un des des résultats de ce scrutin il
y a pas eu cette division ce soir et la
droite a voté sa mesure quelle votait
aussi depuis 2018 mais la question du
moment où votre l'article 7 c'est
justement notre souhait nous c'est pas
seulement de faire un score c'est de
raccorder ce qui est en crise la
politique et la démocratie donc le
régime politique actuel et en même temps
la démocratisation sociale c'était ça la
question c'est que cet articulation
c'est aller-retour vous voyez cette ce
côté vivant qui peut faire bouger les
points de vue il faut retirer ça il faut
retirer cette réforme vous pensez que
c'est encore possible après ce vote ce
soir il y a encore des chances que la
forme n'aille pas au bout selon vous en
tout cas c'est une possibilité c'est une
hypothèse que nous allons encourager de
toutes nos forces de tout homme
d'ailleurs le débat n'est pas terminé
il reste beaucoup d'articles importants
il reste dimanche soir mais s'il fallait
prendre plus de temps je peux vous dire
que les élus commis sont prêts à prendre
du temps pour le débat
retrouver une solution et après il y a
le mouvement social il y a l'expression
des Français avec des civilisations oui
samedi la manifestation c'est pour ça
que attendez voilà enfin je vous le dis
il faut faire attention on est en train
de jouer la question de la cohésion de
l'unité nationale là unité sociale on
est en train de jouer oui sur quelque
chose de très important et excusez-moi
mais aucun amendement changé après avoir
eu une Assemblée nationale qui a donné
une respectabilité au rassemblement
national vous voyez dans quelle
situation on est comme épreuve
démocratique et bien merci merci à vous
allez pouvoir laisser votre place
de fil des sénateurs socialistes pour
une réaction effectivement à cette
information de la soirée autour de
minuit 10 le Sénat a voté et adopter
l'article 7 de la réforme des retraites
je vous redonne le chiffre pour 201
contre 115 c'était il y a donc
maintenant 20 minutes bonsoir Patrick
kaner merci de m'avoir rejoint sur le
plateau de public c'est une défaite pour
la gauche sénatoriale qui vient de se
jouer surprise en la matière dire la
droite sénatoriale même si nous avons vu
chez les centristes chez l'air que
certains votent être quelques ouais il
manque quelques quelques voix 25 mais
aucune surprise en la matière la droite
altoriale voulait voter articles 7 il a
obtenu parce que je tiens à dire c'est
qu'on s'est bien battu permettez-moi de
le dire très très simplement c'est bien
battu avec
des arguments qui montrent que l'article
7 qui correspond finalement à une
réforme comptable aurait pu être dire
concentrer changer potentiellement même
annuler par d'autres mesures financières
que nous avons proposé systématiquement
et quand il refusé par la droite donc
l'article 16 aujourd'hui est voté et
nous allons dire aux Français que et
bien on fait payer à 18 millions de
Français grosso modo 20 millions des
efforts qui auraient pu être partagé
différemment dans ce pays la droite
c'est naturel se défend en disant
qu'elle vote une réforme similaire au
projet loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale chaque automne depuis 2018
lorsque le gouvernement lui présente une
telle réforme n'était-il pas gagné
d'avance qu'elle allait la voter et donc
que vous alliez perdre ce combat vous
m'enlevez les mots de la bouche ça
signifie que aujourd'hui la grande
coalition de droite LR libérale autour
de Monsieur Macron est en train de se
constituer
LR ici finalement circuler la soupe aux
présidents Macron dont acte au moins les
masques sont tombés le grand intérêt
finalement cet article 7
ses devoirs que sur une chose qui est
essentielle qui touche des millions de
Français et bien il y a eu une collusion
manifeste une coalition de fait qui
peut-être d'ailleurs deviendra demain
une coalition peut-être que Retailleau
sera nommé pour le ministre dans les
jours à venir est-ce que en attendant ça
possible nomination qui est bien entendu
pour l'instant complètement pas à
l'ordre du jour mais est-ce que la
Premier ministre actuelle reprend un peu
du souffle grâce au vote de la droite
sénatoriale est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron va
reprendre des couleurs dans l'opinion
grâce à ce vote ce soir tout d'abord le
la loi n'est pas totalement votée à ce
stade il reste jusqu'à dimanche soir
minuit au Sénat pour
ignorer les vins articles il nous reste
encore 13 articles à travailler ce n'est
pas fini nous allons continuer à
argumenter à défendre nos amendements à
défendre notre volonté finalement de
défendre les Français
et si la loi n'est pas votée globalement
bien cela signifiera l'article 7 n'est
pas voté au bout du bout donc que la
droite a gagné une victoire fait une
victoire mais ce n'est pas encore la
guerre une bataille nous sommes
aujourd'hui toujours en train de lutter
de résister même si on nous oppose
beaucoup de d'éléments de règlement qui
nous empêche finalement de parler autant
que nous voulons j'allais y venir
Patrick kaner parce que on a suivi sur
Public Sénat in extenso même très tard
jusqu'à 3h30 du matin hier tout ce qui
s'est passé autour de l'examen de cet
article 7 puisque vous avez des battus
pendant de nombreuses heures sur cet
article et que vous avez fait railler
avec tous les outils du règlement on
peut le dire que dire de cette séquence
elle va marquer les esprits c'était un
niveau de tension entre la droite et la
gauche inattariale qui avait été qui
n'avait jamais été atteint vous lui il y
aura un avant et un après article 7 de
cette loi scélérate de réforme des
retraites de notre pays pour le Sénat
notamment pour le Sénat notamment parce
que c'est la première fois que la
majorité sur la toriale au taux de son
président ce que je regrette monsieur
brut
[Musique]
utilise les amendements prioritaires qui
font tomber de nos amendements qui
utilisent l'article 38 c'est à dire que
un vote pour un vote contre et on arrête
le débat donc on clôture le débat qui
utilise l'article 42 il vient d'être
utilisé pour nous empêcher de faire des
explications de vote et bien tout cela
tout cela montre simplement que
finalement la droite a peur du débat et
je crois que je n'ai pas effectivement
l'histoire habituelle du Sénat je le
regrette nous le regrettons parce que
c'est vrai que cette chambre a été
habituée à respect très profond pour son
épisode d'opposition ce n'est plus le
cas aujourd'hui merci Patrick canin pour
cette réaction à notre micro nous on va
les rejoindre notre journaliste Mathias
sarez Mathias pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous rejoignent à minuit 33 le Sénat
adopté l'article 7 dans quelles
conditions et bien écoutez vous le savez
ce matin la Conférence des Présidents
avait décidé d'activer l'article 42 10
du règlement intérieur du Sénat ce qui
limitait donc à une prise de parole par
groupe au moment du vote de cet article
7 une prise de parole donc qui a donc
pris la forme d'un plaidoyer pour ou
contre cet article 7 qui est charnière
dans la loi pour les socialistes c'est
la chef de fil sur la question des
retraites Monique Lubin qui est allé au
micro je vous propose de l'écouter
histoire on retiendra à Monsieur du soft
que votre nom et votre nom monsieur du
monsieur le ministre du soft restera à
jamais attaché restera à jamais attaché
à celui d'une réforme qui fera revenir
presque
40 ans en arrière
oui oui presque 40 ans en arrière et
franchement j'espère quand votre fort
intérieur ça vous parle et ça ne vous
fait pas particulièrement plaisir
à gauche toujours c'est la communiste
Eliane assassy qui a défendu la position
de son groupe eleanasasi qu'on avait
énormément entendu depuis le début des
débats notamment sur une complicité
entre les LR du Sénat et le gouvernement
la droite sénatoriale menée par Monsieur
retaille
au nous avec le Parlement et madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales et les rapporteurs ont violé le
règlement du Sénat en déclarant
irrecevable des abonne qui était
pourtant pleinement sur cet article 7
toutes les procédures possibles et
imaginables ont été dégainées par
plusieurs présidents de groupe
favorables à cet article 7 sais-je le
redis la démonstration d'un coup de
force monsieur le Président vous vous
êtes assis sur votre propre règlement et
la prétendue sagesse du Sénat on a pris
un coup
des prises de parole à gauche qui ont
piqué aux vif le chef de la majorité
sanatoriale ici Bruno Retailleau très
vif dans ses paroles je vous propose de
l'écouter bien sûr que nous allons bien
sûr nous allons voter cet article 7 vous
espériez qu'on ne le vote pas ce soir
nous le voterons ce soir nous le
voterons parce que il va permettre de
sauver le régime de retraite par
répartition bien sûr bien sûr c'est un
levier budgétaire mais ceux qui se
moquent des chiffres se moquent des gens
derrière les chiffres il y a les
déficits derrière les défis visites il y
a l'argent des Français derrière
l'argent français il y a la peine des
Français
le scrutin public a donc donné son
résultat
220 votes pour 115 contre il reste
maintenant un peu moins d'une heure ici
de débat dans l'hémicycle avant la
clôture pour aujourd'hui oui Mathias
tout à fait et le président du sénage à
arraché qui a décidé de continuer avec
l'examen effectivement des articles
alors que Monsieur Hainaut va pouvoir
nous rejoindre et s'installer allez-y
prenez place monsieur le sénateur mais
donc le président du Sénat est décidé de
continuer après l'article 7 l'examen des
articles qui suivent pour donc on
imagine ne perdre aucune minute de
séance bonsoir Olivier merci de nous
rejoindre vous êtes le chef de fil du
groupe centriste sur cette réforme des
retraites une réaction sur ce vote le
Sénat qui adopte 200 une voix pour 115
contre cet article 7 qui est un peu le
réacteur nucléaire de la réforme des
retraites et que le décalage de 62 à 64
ans alors c'est un votant en
responsabilité après avoir entendu nos
deux rapporteurs avoir longuement
débattus c'est un vote qui permet de
donner un avenir au système de de
répartition et de garantir le montant et
le niveau des retraites et donc nous
avons voté en responsabilité vous voyez
que du score 201 voient pour 115 contre
habituellement les scrutins depuis le
début étaient plutôt à 90 contre donc il
y a bien des sénateurs venus d'autres
groupes qui ont voté contre la mesure
est-ce que vous êtes sûr qu'il y a comme
cela une majorité de la droite et du
centre qui est unanime sur la question
c'est un vote en responsabilité il n'en
reste pas moins vrai que sur la question
du travail sur la question du sens du
travail sur la question du calendrier
sur la question du paritarisme du
dialogue social nous avons évoqué tous
ces sujets dans la discussion générale
nous avons dit aussi que il y avait
urgence à retisser
le lien sociaux et à réouvrir la
discussion avec les partenaires sociaux
je pense par exemple à la CFDT mais là
précisément en responsabilité au moment
de vote majoritairement nous nous sommes
exprimés en faveur de cet article et
donc qui ont manqué à l'appel une
dizaine contre une dizaine qui se sont
abstenus c'est ça chacun est libre de de
son vote et naturellement c'est c'est
aussi ça la dignité et la grandeur de du
Parlement et je pense que ce qui fait
aussi la différence par rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est cette
volonté que nous avons d'aller au bout
du texte c'est l'honneur du Sénat et
l'honneur de la démocratie
représentative monsieur Hainaut se vote
intervient au lendemain d'une grande
journée de mobilisation peut-être l'une
des plus importantes depuis le début de
ce mouvement de depuis le début de
l'année 2023 qu'est-ce que ça dit au
moment où vous avez la rue qui est très
mobilisée le Sénat qui n'écoute pas
cette rue et qui vote le texte du
Gouvernement le rôle la responsabilité
comment est-ce que vous avez vécu toute
cette séquence vous ah ben je souhaite
séquence je dois dire que l'obstruction
systématique des amendements quasi
ridicules sur des dates sur des heures
des nombres d'amendements voilà ça n'est
pas la tradition du Sénat et c'est vrai
que il y a un avant et un après ça
ressemble beaucoup plus à une forme de
mélangeonisation des esprits et la
gauche c'est
mélenchoniser et je pense que
je pense qu'ils se sont fait mal
voyez-vous voilà s'il y a un avant et un
après je pense qu'ils se sont fait mal
parce que tout ça n'a plus rien à voir
avec le de la tradition sociale
démocrate du Parti socialiste
d'autrefois alors ils vous renvoie
l'argument disons vous avez eu recours à
des articles du règlement qui n'avaient
jamais étudié été utilisé dans ces
conditions pour forcer le débat leur
faire tomber des amendements et c'est ça
aussi qui sait jouer ces deux derniers
jours autour de l'article 7 du président
Larcher et celle du président Marseille
du rotaïo et de nous tous la majorité
sénatoriale c'est précisément d'aller au
bout de ce texte parce qu'imaginait
l'assemblée ne se prononce pas le Sénat
de se prononce en mais les gens ils vont
dire mais à quoi il servent ces
parlementaires notre responsabilité
c'est de s'exprimer on a quand même 120
heures de débats mais c'est d'aller au
bout du texte et ça c'était essentiel
j'ai une dernière question puis après on
pourra écouter Martin lévrier le
représentant de ici la majorité
présidentielle mais un dernier mot sur
la suite du texte il reste jusqu'à
dimanche soir pour pour examiner les 20
articles il en reste donc 13 est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est possible alors
qu'il reste encore à l'heure où on se
parle exactement plus de 1000
amendements à examiner on va tout mettre
en oeuvre pour y arriver et si on y
arrive pas je pense que ce sera une très
grosse responsabilité pour la gauche qui
radicalisée nous on veut tenir notre
rôle de parlementaire tenir la place du
Sénat et la place de la démocratie
représentative c'est toute notre honneur
et bien merci merci pour cette réaction
au micro de public c'est naol vous êtes
le chef de fil centriste ici au Sénat
sur cette réforme il est minuit 42 si
vous nous rejoignez sur l'antenne de
public c'est naï il y a une demi-heure
autour de minuit 10 le Sénat a adopté
l'article 7 mesures phare du projet de
loi de réforme des retraites juste avant
il y avait eu les explications de vote
écoutez l'explication de vote du camp de
la majorité présidentielle avec Martin
lévrier oui l'article 7 demande un
effort aux Français il n'est pas
question delaunier oui cet effort est
indispensable et il est indispensable en
particulier pour les jeunes et je suis
très étonné que dans cette hémicycle
nous ayons quasiment jamais aborder les
jeunes je regrette aussi toujours que
les gens qui sont à ma droite et ce
besoin systématique de parler quand les
autres ont la parole
c'est assez pénible et cet effort est
vraiment et moi je veux parler à notre
jeunesse et leur dire qu'à travers cet
effort que nous demandons à tous c'est
pour eux que nous le faisons pour que
dans 30 ans quand ils seront un peu
moins jeunes ils se disent oui notre
système de retraite fonctionne oui le
système para répartition est un système
fort qui nous protège et qui protégera
plus tard les la jeunesse il est minuit
43 sur un thème de Public Sénat donc le
Sénat qui a adopté et bien cet article 7
Guillaume Gontard bonsoir vous êtes le
chef de fil président donc du groupe des
écologistes ici au Sénat 200 une voie
pour 115 contre vous avez donc perdu ce
bras de fer qui avait commencé hier à
19h avec la droite sénatoriale autour de
cet article 7
on va dire qu'on a peut-être perdu cette
bataille mais je pense qu'en fait
réellement ceux qui ont perdu ce sont
les Françaises et les Français ce soir
franchement oui cet article 7 qui a été
voté ce n'est pas le texte on va se
battre d'arrache-pied sur l'ensemble des
articles qui vont qui vont venir jusqu'à
dimanche minuit et on sera là on sera
présent avec l'ensemble des groupes de
gauche et écologistes mais oui c'est une
terrible régression sociale deux ans en
plus dans la vie des gens ce n'est pas
rien et la manière dont l'on fait les
républicains Bruno Retailleau ce choix
de corps se tait le débat de censurer le
débat l'épisode d'hier soir qui était
lamentable et puis c'était article 7 qui
a été voté oui mais dans des conditions
qu'il n'auraient pas dû être oui on a
besoin de débattre on a besoin de
discuter on a besoin d'échanger le débat
à la parlementaire et indispensable on
est au Sénat on est ici au Sénat on est
là justement pour échanger et le fait
que la droite refuse cet échange et
particulièrement
désastreux est-ce que la droite c'est
naturel elle est centriste il donne une
bouffée d'air une bouffée d'oxygène à
l'exécutif à Elisabeth borne qui voilà
on est à sa sixième journée de
mobilisation contre sa réforme qui se
trouve la dernière roue de secours de
l'exécutif d'Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs
je note Emmanuel Macron ne le vois plus
alors il a son représentant ici Bruno
Retailleau qui est présent qui est là
qui fait le service après-vente mais moi
j'aimerais bien un moment donné entendre
étendre Emmanuel Macron j'ai pu
interroger Elisabeth borne tout à
l'heure en question d'actualité pour
justement lui demander le retrait de ce
texte parce que je pense qu'on va pas
pouvoir aller très loin comme ça avec la
mobilisation qui peut y avoir avec
l'attente qui peut y avoir avec la
colère qui peut y avoir dans notre pays
et oui ils ont une très grande
responsabilité justement qu'est-ce que
vous dites à tous ces centaines de
milliers de Français peut-être million
de Français qui sont mobilisés dans la
rue depuis au moins 6 rendez-vous avec
ses appels à la manifestation syndicale
ils doivent continuer à se mobiliser
ils se disent pas que finalement cette
cette réforme elle va finir par passer
non cette réforme ne passera pas moi je
leur dis ne lâchez rien ne lâchez rien
au contraire mobilisation après
mobilisation les Françaises et les
Français sont encore plus encore plus
nombreux les syndicats sont soudés on
est là l'ensemble des groupes de gauche
écologistes au Sénat à l'Assemblée pour
faire leur porte-voix en se battra
jusqu'au bout et on va gagner merci
Guillaume gantard pour cette réaction au
micro de Public Sénat je vais vous
laisser votre place à Monsieur lévrier
qui se trouve juste ici et juste pour
rappeler ce chiffre pour 201 contre 115
le Sénat adopté c'est au tour de minuit
10 l'article 7 l'article fin de la
réforme des retraites bonsoir Martin
lévrier bonsoir merci de nous avoir
rejoint vous êtes sénateur on dit le
groupe RDPI c'est le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle ici au Sénat une
réaction à ce score est-ce que vous
remercier ce soir la droite et le centre
du Sénat d'avoir et bien voté le texte
du Gouvernement je remercie toutes les
personnes de bonne volonté qui ont
étudié ce texte depuis le début et qui
en ont compris l'importance il s'agit
pas de remercier la droite le centre
nous nous essayons de faire une loi pour
tous les Français dans le coeur nous
aussi donc
dans tous ceux qui ont voté pour et tous
ceux qui ont participé au débat je les
remercie oui bien sûr ouais
est-ce que vous remerciez aussi Bruno
grâce à qui Elisabeth borne peut-être ce
soir vient d'avoir une victoire ou en
tout cas remporter une bataille dans
dans cette dans cette réforme je crois
que vous ne m'avez pas compris je n'irai
pas ce terrain là quand on fait une
réforme des retraites c'est pour tous
les Français et c'est en particulier je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure en particulier
pour la jeunesse pour qu'elle lui assure
que elle aussi aura une retraite dans 30
ou 40 ans donc il s'agit pas d'une
victoire pour Madame borne pour Monsieur
Retailleau pour Martin lévrier il s'agit
d'une victoire pour les français pour la
protection des Français et pour un
système qui est extraordinaire qui est à
ce système d'un système de la solidarité
intergénérationnelle et je crois qu'on a
tellement oublié ces mots là ces
derniers temps dans ce débat on a aussi
vu qu'il y avait encore une majorité de
Français dans les dernières études
d'opinion qui dit encore que et bien
c'est français ne souhaite pas cette
mesure d'âge le Sénat qui vote contre la
vie de majorité de Français selon ses
études qu'est-ce que ça dit ça dit ça
dit d'abord que c'est un sujet qui est
complexe et qu'à chaque fois qu'une
réforme des retraites a été proposée
hormis 1980 bien sûr les Français
étaient contre et on peut le comprendre
puisque c'est un système c'est une loi
générale pour l'ensemble des Français
qui va les toucher chacun à titre
individuel et qu'on ne peut pas
expliquer chacun individuel mais chacun
aujourd'hui je crois chaque Français est
capable de bien comprendre que quand on
parle de solidarité de tous on peut
comprendre ce besoin de prendre un peu
de recul et de se rendre compte que si
on ne protège pas ce système on met en
péril toute notre jeunesse et ça c'est
je crois aujourd'hui essentiel donc oui
les Français sont inquiets je le
comprends oui on demande d'effort et il
faut le dire et le redire c'est un
effort qui est demandé mais à travers
cet effort cette réforme fait un nombre
de d'œuvres sociales pas d'oeuvre
sociale pardon excusez-moi c'est pas le
mot de progrès sociaux pour les en
particulier pour les retraités les plus
faibles qui est très importants donc
aujourd'hui nous allons pouvoir
tranquillement j'espère étudier au Sénat
et vraiment l'étudier plutôt que de
faire des débats sans fin et sans
intérêts qui sont des jeux de procédure
pénible j'ai une dernière question et
après on ira rejoindre notre journaliste
Mathias sarez en tribune mais j'ai une
dernière question est-ce que ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers jours autour de
l'examen d'article 7 avait été préparé
entre la majorité présidentielle la
majorité de droite et l'exécutif pas que
je sache c'est ce qui a été sous-entendu
par des sénateurs qui voilà qui estiment
qu'il a pu avoir comme ça une entente
cordiale une entente en tout cas de
pratiquer avec l'exécutif de la part de
la Commission pour préparer la façon ça
allait se dérouler dans l'hémistice non
je crois qu'il y a une volonté d'une
sécurité de sénateurs d'aller au bout de
ce texte et de trouver les moyens les
plus intelligents pour aller au bout de
ce texte il y a une opposition qui veut
jouer je n'ai jamais prononcé ce mot
jusqu'à aujourd'hui j'ai essayé de
l'éviter mais c'est un venu impossible
aujourd'hui qui veut jouer l'obstruction
quasi systématique au lieu de rentrer
dans un vrai débat il faut donc utiliser
malheureusement parfois des moyens qui
correspondent à ce qu'ils veulent c'est
à dire cette obstruction
idiote et qui ne sert à rien et bien
merci pour cette réaction merci ces mots
à notre micro sur le plateau ici un de
publics au cœur de la salle des
conférences qui jouxte l'hémicycle alors
qu'effectivement ça y est la séance a
été levée je rappelle cette information
à minuit 10 le Sénat a adopté l'article
7 de la réforme des retraites cet
article qui décale l'âge de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans pour en parler
on va rejoindre mathiasaraez Mathias
vous avez tous suivi de ces débats pour
publier cela depuis 22h racontez-nous
comment ça s'est passé et bien écoutez
les débats ont été très jamais ici dans
l'hémicycle il y a eu effectivement une
accélération vers la fin des amendements
qui étaient déposés il y avait eu
beaucoup d'amendements à plus de 70 au
total à partir de la reprise et c'est
donc un article du règlement du Sénat
qui a accéléré vers ce vote il y a eu le
droit à simplement une explication de
votre par une personne par groupe et
nous sommes donc passé à ce scrutin
public et donc un vote qui a été
largement remporté 200 une voix pour 115
contre Quentin l'article 7 et donc
adopter sur cette mesure d'âge qui
reporte l'âge de départ de 62 à 64 ans
merci Mathias c'est donc l'information
principale de la soirée vous l'avez vécu
en direct et en intégralité sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat depuis 22h
l'article 7 celui sur la mesure d'âge de
la réforme des retraites a été adoptée
après plus de 24 heures de débat en tout
cas les débats avaient commencé
hier à 19h et donc cette mesure d'âge a
été adoptée 200 une voix pour 115
comptes ce que je vous propose c'est de
revivre l'un des moments de plus forte
tension autour de cet article 7 entre la
droite sénatoriale et la gauche
sénatoriale on va revoir cet extrait de
ce qui s'est déroulé autour de cet
article 7 et un moment donc de fortes
tensions qui s'est joué ces dernières
heures regarde
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement vise à ne pas décaler l'âge
légal de 6214 ans et ne pas accéder
ne pas accélérer la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme Touraine la réforme proposée par
le gouvernement apparaît effectivement
injuste particulièrement parce que là je
l'égale de départ de la retraite serait
décédé et que le nombre d'années de
cotisations
profondément opposés à cette réforme qui
n'est ni plus ni moins que le plus
injuste des impôts sur la vie notre
système de retraite n'est pas menacé à
long terme il doit simplement faire face
aux conséquences momentanées du papy
boom dans les décennies de 2030 à 2050
et d'autres choix sont possibles ils ont
été longuement exposés ici depuis le
début de nos débats
de plus en se conjuguant à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui réduit la durée
de l'indemnisation et à celle du RSA
cette réforme va précariser les
travailleurs seniors qui voient leur
durée d'indemnisation chômage réduite de
8 mois et non donc plus que le RSA pour
vivre si bien sûr ils ont droit qui peut
croire raisonnablement que ce que
propose le gouvernement dans sa réforme
est un quelconque qui est fait
amortisseur sur cette paupérisation en
marche des travailleurs seniors ce
projet de loi de régression sociale
apparaît inacceptable c'est une réforme
injuste
inutile et une efficace il s'agit donc
ici de supprimer l'article de ce projet
même la présidence Rossignol merci
monsieur le Président j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure l'intersyndicale
non pas que je veux absolument mettre sa
porte-parole dans cette hémicycle mais
pour connaître le mouvement social le
mouvement syndical depuis de nombreuses
années je sais mesurer ce que signifie
un mouvement syndical uni dans un moment
comme celui qu'on vit et je sais aussi
ce que signifie la mobilisation de 1
million 500 000 à 3 millions de
personnes contre une réforme
l'intersyndicale s'est réuni ce soir
elle a donné ses nouvelles
préconisations je vais vous les lire
je pense que c'est pas inintéressant
pour vous non plus même si vous les
soutenez pas c'est toujours bien de
savoir ce que font les autres le 16
février face à l'absence de réponse du
gouvernement l'Inter syndicale a amené
appelé à mettre la France à la reine 7
mars c'est une journée historique par
l'ampleur de ses gravés de ses
mobilisations à ce jour s'est
mobilisations énormes conduite par une
interne de syndicaturique unique non
reçu aucune réponse de la part du
gouvernement cela ne peut plus durer le
silence du président de la République
constitue un problème démocratique grave
qui conduit un manquablement à une
situation qui pourrait devenir explosive
en responsabilité l'intersyndicale
s'adressera au président de la
République
l'intersyndicale appelle à une nouvelle
mobilisation interprofessionnelle ce
samedi 11 mars puis la semaine prochaine
à une manifestation le jour de la
commission mix paritaire elle appelle la
population à continuer à l'obligation et
les actions encore plus massivement pour
dire non à cette réforme injuste et
brutale
voyez-vous
cette intersey syndicale elle prend à la
fois la responsabilité de continuer
d'accompagner le mouvement social et
nous nous devons être à la hauteur de
cette responsabilité monsieur le
ministre vous ne pouvez pas continuer de
ne pas répondre au mouvement social et à
l'intersyndical et nous chers collègues
en votant nos amendements de suppression
de l'article 7 nous permettrions à tout
le monde de sortir la tête haute de
cette affaire madame la Présidente
oui mais merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues mesdames Messieurs
les messieurs encore les membres du
gouvernement je crois qu'il n'y a aucune
mais vraiment strictement aucune donnée
chiffrée qui ne permet de justifier que
l'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ainsi que
l'allongement des trimestres de
cotisation et nécessaire nous en avons
déjà fait la démonstration lors de nos
précédents débats je crois que nous
sommes assez offensif et nous
continuerons donc à dire et à proposer
que des économies et enfin à dire que
des économies peuvent être réalisés
ailleurs sans porter atteinte au régime
actuel de retraite selon la l'Institut
national d'études démographique
l'espérance de vie doit aussi être
appréciée en tenant compte de l'âge
auquel il y a un vrai risque
d'incapacité dans les gestes de la vie
quotidienne ce concept rejoint en
quelque sorte celui de l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé que nous défendons et
bien super collègues cette espérance de
vie prenant en compte l'incapacité à
effectuer les gestes de la vie
quotidienne se situent en France à
64,1 an pour les femmes et
62,7 ans pour les hommes la réforme donc
actuelle qui nous est proposée par le
gouvernement avec la complicité de la
droite sénatoriale aggrave le risque de
liquider les pensions de retraite à un
âge où le retraité n'est plus où la
retraité et plus en mesure de profiter
comme il ou elle le souhaiterait du
fruit de son labeur nous maintenons donc
que votre projet est celui de la
destruction sociale et après ce que ce
qui vient d'être vient d'être dit par
Madame Rossignol je le répète il
faudrait peut-être que vous entendiez à
la fois ce qui s'est dit exprimé
aujourd'hui dans les rues des villes et
qu'elles soient petites moyennes ou
grandes et que vous écoutiez aussi et
que vous sachiez lire le communiqué le
communiqué de l'Inter syndical
merci monsieur le Président avec cette
article 7 il s'agit en effet du recul de
l'âge de la retraite et de
l'accélération de la hausse des durées
de cotisations qui sont censées réduire
ou lutter contre les déficits de notre
système de protection sociale au passage
monsieur le ministre quand vous nous
dites tout à l'heure
que l'âge de départ sans décote sera
maintenu à 67 ans et ne sera pas à 69
ans j'espère que vous n'imaginez pas que
les Français vous remercient largement
parce que vous risquez d'être encore un
peu déçu au passage toujours je trouve
quand même assez inquiétant de constater
que
en fait la politique c'est
identifier des problèmes et il apporter
des réponses et si certains d'entre vous
sont assis à la droite de cette
hémicycle d'autres à la gauche de cette
hémicycle c'est que nous avons des
options différentes pour répondre à des
problématiques que nous pouvons parfois
identifier ensemble or je vois que
beaucoup ici
préféreraient un passage en force qu'un
débat sur des solutions alternatives à
ce report de l'âge de la retraite et les
Français le sentent bien qu'on leur
refuse ce débat c'est ça aussi qu'elle
aimait de plus en plus nombreux dans la
rue parce que voilà un débat de société
au sens noble du terme qui pourrait
faire en sorte que nos concitoyens
renouent avec la politique mais vous la
refusez encore une fois certains d'entre
vous préféreraient passer en force et
enfin puisqu'il s'agit de prétendus
déficit j'ai eu l'occasion tout à
l'heure de montrer en quoi le coût
social de ce report de l'âge allait être
très conséquent sur la vie associative
démocratique dans nos communes etc je
pense qu'il leur sera aussi en termes de
pure des pensées sociales par
l'augmentation des arrêts de travail par
la baisse du niveau de pension qui va
faire en sorte que de nouvelles dépenses
sociales vont devoir déployer pour
empêcher que des retraités
et donc je crois qu'il n'est absolument
pas question d'économie avec ce projet
nous sommes en direct sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat la chaîne qui bouleverse
ces programmes pour suivre au plus près
l'examen de l'article 7 sur la mesure
d'âge de la réforme des retraites nous
arrivons dans les 10 dernières prises de
parole sur ces amendements de
suppression de l'article 7 retournant
l'hémistice cycle le taux d'emploi des
seniors et de 35%. donc allongez la
durée créera des retraités pauvres vous
nous dites c'est pas le sujet on vous a
proposé de financer autrement
t'accélérer riche non les dividendes
sûrement pas élargir l'assiette pas
possible gagner la bataille de l'emploi
attendez la loi travail l'égalité
salariale c'est la grande cause du
quinquennat vous allez voir taxer la
rente sûrement pas vous allez tuer le
ruissellement on vous a dit vous avez
une question démocratique vous êtes
minoritaire 3,5 millions de travailleurs
et de travailleuses dans la rue vous
avez assumé monsieur le ministre on
assume d'être impopulaire et donc pour
vous une seule solution deux ans plus
deux ans qui vont peser sur les classes
populaires les essentiel très utile
celles et ceux qui ont tenu le pays à
bout de bras pendant le covid ceux qui
ont des carrières arrachées les horaires
décalés ceux qui triment et que le
travail concasse le cœur et les esprits
mais vous vous nous parlez justice
travailler
alors que pour nous il faudrait partager
partager le travail le savoir et les
richesses enfin si vous n'êtes pas
convaincu un dernier
argument est-ce que vous pensez
sincèrement que c'est le moment même
Olivier Vérand l'a dit
occupons-nous d'abord de l'inflation du
prix de l'électricité des salaires de
l'emploi de la formation et de la
réindustrialisation du pays avant de
voler les deux plus belles années des
retraites seul le ministre il est temps
de battre en retraite et de retirer
votre projet de loi
chez Laurent
oui bien merci monsieur le Président
tout à l'heure le président Retailleau
nous a dit quelque chose qui était faux
nous a dit depuis 40 ans personne n'est
revenu sur une réforme des retraites qui
avait été votée c'est faux en 1980 il y
a 40 ans la gauche a voté une réforme
historique qui a passé l'âge de départ à
la retraite de 65 ans à 60 ans c'était
une des réformes qui ont marqué le
siècle oui qui ont marqué un siècle de
progrès sociaux comme les congés payés à
une certaine époque comme la réduction
de la journée du temps de travail à
d'autres etc donc il y a eu un progrès
historique et la vérité c'est qu'en fait
vous ne l'avez jamais accepté donc
ensuite on a eu le droit à Balladur en
93 à Fillon en 2003 et Sarkozy en 2010
et les 62 ans c'est déjà vous c'est vous
les 62 ans c'est vous qui avez institué
les 62 ans en 2010 et aujourd'hui vous
voulez passer à 64 ans
et si vous étiez resté au pouvoir si
vous étiez resté au pouvoir sans
discontinuer on discuterait pas 62 ou 64
on serait toujours restés à 65 et on
serait probablement à 67 aujourd'hui
parce que vous auriez rajouté deux ans
comme dodo dans d'autres pays européens
donc en vérité ce projet-là c'est votre
projet depuis toujours et le et ce qu'on
a entendu de la part du rapporteur
Savary qui s'éclipse au moment où je
parle de lui c'est une fable c'est une
fable l'idée
l'idée
l'idée que vous êtes finalement obligé
d'en poser les 64 ans parce qu'on a fait
les 40 parce que toi Marisol Touraine
appelle les 43 nuitées c'est de la
blague en vérité depuis 1981 votre rêve
c'est de revenir à 65 ans et aujourd'hui
vous progressez alors effectivement
monsieur Retailleau a raison c'est une
réforme de droite à laquelle le
gouvernement aujourd'hui sera lit qu'il
mette en œuvre que vous allez soutenir
très fort mais elle est à contretemps
elle est archaïque elle sera combattue
par la elle ne sera pas appliquée
chers collègues républicains
vous jouez avec le feu
c'est bien entendu l'argumentaire de
votre président de groupe monsieur
Retailleau
son argumentaire c'est
nous avons le courage de faire des
réformes à populaires
parce que nous savons mieux que le
peuple ce qui est bon pour la nation
alors on le fait une fois
et puis on le fait deux fois et puis on
croit qu'on va pouvoir continuer comme
ça
pendant des lustres parce figurez-vous
que non pour une raison simple c'est que
la première fois les Français ils
peuvent y croire vous allez sauver le
système de répartition vous allez
répondre aux problèmes de du temps et
les choses vont être meilleures pour la
nation
et puis il se rendent compte que réforme
après réforme c'est pire pour eux c'est
pire pour le pays donc il ne vous croit
plus
il ne vous croit plus et jamais dans
l'histoire le général de Gaulle nous
aurait eu comme raisonnement
oui oui
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
chaque fois
chaque fois que le général de Gaulle a
eu un doute
eu un doute sur le soutien des Français
il a été devant le peuple il a fait un
référendum vous vous avez
peur de faire cela
conséquence de ces attitudes elle est
conséquente de ces attitudes
accumuler dans le temps ou vous
théorisez que la bonne politique c'est
celle qui doit être faite contre le
peuple et la même le peuple à s'abstenir
elle amène le peuple à accumuler la
colère elle amène le peuple à se
démoraliser sur l'avenir de la France
elle amène le cap vers l'extrême droite
merci Monsieur Ouzoulias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre j'ai posé une
question et j'ai pas eu de réponse donc
vous vous me permettrez de reposer ma
question elle est très simple lors de la
campagne électorale le président de la
République avait expliqué que le recul
de l'âge de 2 ans permettrait de
financer un minimum retraite à 1200
euros pour tout le monde on sait
aujourd'hui que seul si si je peux je
peux vous redonner les propos de
Monsieur Macron on sait maintenant que
seuls 10000 à 20000 retraités pourront
en bénéficier je vous repose donc une
nouvelle fois la question quel est le
gain budgétaire de cette réforme des
retraites les économistes évaluent à
0,6% du PIB le surcroît de recettes
budgétaire dans 10 ans est-ce que vous
nous confirmez maintenant cette
évaluation et je pense chers collègues
qu'il faudrait prendre conscience comme
l'a dit très bien le président
Retailleau qu'il s'agit aussi d'une
réforme budgétaire c'est un point c'est
très important que les Français sachent
que là on est en train de discuter d'un
nouvel impôt Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président est-ce que ça vole des livres
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mais chers collègues commencez
par ça vous a pas échappé de temps en
temps on a eu des comparaisons
je vais vous parler de l'Allemagne pour
vous faire vibrer dans votre
enthousiasme le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale un chiffre 20%
c'est le taux de pauvreté c'est le taux
de pauvreté des retraités en Allemagne
et puis allez c'est le même en Irlande
et pourtant l'âge de départ est à 66 ans
soit 10 % de plus qu'en France
60% c'est le pourcentage de pays ayant
fait machine arrière après avoir
privatisé leur régime d'Orth retraite
diminution du taux de couverture baisse
des allocations de retraite aggravation
des inégalités de gens et de revenus
c'est-à-dire croyez la comparaison
européenne c'est charge la preuve
y compris par y compris des droits de
libérales excusez-moi de le dire mais
par des droits de libérales
la deuxième chose c'est que tout à
l'heure on a eu la confirmation d'autres
collègues l'ont affirmé mais là on a un
moment de clarification politique
le président Retailleau a été très clair
il a dit c'est une réforme de droite
donc nous sommes en train de discuter du
dréforme de droite et ça m'a fait penser
on a tous des loisirs etc j'ai pensé aux
formidable film le salaire de la peur
où il y a quatre aventuriers qui part
cupidité s'en vont à défier la nature là
on était dans les critères de pénalité
est-ce qu'on vient de vivre depuis jeudi
par le vote de la droite de la première
partie de la loi et par la défense de
rajouter deux années de plus vous êtes
en train de nous proposer de proposer
aux Français la retraite de la peur pour
les obliger à rentrer dans la
capitalisation voilà l'enjeu de cette
réforme merci Madame baragas
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
minis 70% des Français et plus de 90%
des salariés nous le savons sont opposés
à ce report de 62 64 ans de l'âge de
départ à la retraite le président de la
République avance qu'il faut que les
Français travaillent plus nous proposons
quant à nous qu'il travaille tous ce qui
permettrait d'abander les caisses des
assurances sociales avec les cotisations
nouvelles la dernière réforme
paramétrique des retraites qui fait
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite de
60 à 62 ans évoqué par Pierre Laurent
tout à l'heure imposé par Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2010 a eu pour conséquence
selon lunédique de plongée 100 000
seniors dans le chômage de longue durée
entre 2010 et 2022 il ne s'agit pas on
peut le dire d'une brillante réussite
imagine-t-on un métallurgiste ou un
salarié à la chaîne chez Renault qui
travaille souvent en 3,8 continuent à
occuper un poste de travail dans une
entreprise à 64 ans une infirmière me
disait récemment j'ai terminé ma
carrière émotionnel par un arrêt maladie
suite à un burnout et une période de
chômage de deux ans comment une
infirmière une aide-soignante pourra
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans voire plus
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
c'est augmenter la période de non emploi
des seniors pour les seniors risquant de
ne pas toucher d'indemnités de chômage
durant ces années ils seront poussés
vers les minima sociaux qui ne
permettent pas de vivre dignement est-ce
là la description d'une réforme de
gauche monsieur le ministre je ne crois
pas et si ce n'est pas l'indigent index
seniors voté dans l'article 2 de votre
loi qui risque d'inciter les entreprises
à garder les plus de 60 ans dans leurs
effectifs l'allongement des carrières va
imm encabrement provoquer un surchaumage
chez les salariés les plus âgés qui
risquent plus de ne pas avoir une
carrière complète ce qui aura un impact
négatif sur leur pension future faire
basculer les dépenses de retraite sur
les indemnités de chômage est une
politique qui n'a aucun sens d'un point
de vue économique pour toutes ces
raisons bien évidemment nous demandons
la suppression de
cette merci
nous en avons terminé avec les
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune je vais s'il vous
plaît je vais consulter la commission
avis de la commission
merci monsieur le Président j'attendais
effectivement
mon tour pour donner la vie de la
commission après tous ces amendements à
répétitifs
qui font pour certains tableaux de la
valeur travail particulièrement
apocalyptique il y a encore des gens
quand même qui je pense pour les choses
différemment
Monsieur Laurent Monsieur Laurent vous
avez dit que certains rêvaient un âge de
retraite à 64 ans mais un monsieur
Laurent moi la retraite à 60 ans pour
moi c'est un cauchemar ça veut dire
qu'on n'aime pas le système par
répartition ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
vu la société la société vieilli
Monsieur Laurent il y a de moins en
moins de naissance la longévité telle
que la retraite l'espérance de vie dure
de plus en plus longtemps et si vous
voulez prendre des mesures qui vont
plomber le système par répartition c'est
que vous n'aimez pas la répartition j'ai
écouté aussi monsieur Sueur monsieur
Sueur qui a fait une explication tout à
fait intéressante mais qui pense que en
travaillant effectivement plus sur la
durée et bien on pourrait peut-être
rendre les gens le plus heureux et bien
non on sait que plus la durée on
travaille sur la durée les 43 ans ça
fait les conséquences c'est qu'il y a
une diminution de la pension moyenne
calculée à de 300 euros lisez l'étude
d'impact je n'ai rien inventé donc ça
veut dire que vous n'aimez pas les
retraités que vous voulez faire des
retraités pauvres c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me tourne vers ce banc l'un
de l'hémicycle
ce banc là de l'hémicycle pense qu'il
faut jouer sur le niveau de l'âge légal
mais chers collègues vous avez raison
vous avez raison parce que ces eux le
seul moyen dans un système pas
répartition de faire en sorte qu'on
arrive à élever le niveau des pensions
faire en sorte qu'on puisse dégager des
recettes supplémentaires et qu'on puisse
faire plus de solidarité mais vous
n'aimez pas la solidarité donc et nous
nous aimons la solidarité
et nous aimons la solidarité et nous
voudrions bien la proposer aux Français
non pas à travers des discours mais à
travers des actes ce sont les articles
suivants qui viennent pour les maires de
famille vous en parlez beaucoup nous
agissons
pour l'usure professionnelle
je vous ai taquiné pour l'usure
professionnelle nous avons des mesures
pour la retraite progressive nous avons
des mesures en conséquence il serait
temps monsieur le Président que nous
puissions passer dans l'examen du texte
les Français attendent de nous que l'on
donne un peu plus de justice sociale à
ce texte il en manque un peu messieurs
les ministres un peu plus de justice
sociale à travers les divers
dispositions que nous souhaiterions
vivement examinés voilà vous l'avez
compris mes chers collègues la vie sera
défavorable de la part de la Commission
la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs en donnant la
vie du gouvernement qui sera défavorable
en réponse aux 70 amendements de
suppression je ne reprendrai pas les
arguments très synthétiques qui ont été
évoqués par Olivier du socle mais je
donnerai quelques principes qui
concernent la fonction publique les
agents de la fonction publique qui sont
effectivement inclus dans cet article 7
et en le faisant je veux me réjouir que
dans cette chambre on puisse débattre de
la situation des agents de la fonction
publique parce que cela n'avait pas été
possible à l'Assemblée nationale et je
pense que c'était dommage de ne pas
évoquer au fond les principes qui
concernent les agents de la fonction
publique et qui sont majoritairement
dans cet article 7 d'abord je le ferai
de façon monsieur le Président très
synthétique pour aller plus vite sur
ensuite l'explication sur les différents
amendements d'abord un principe d'équité
je crois que les Français n'auraient pas
compris que les mesures des efforts qui
concerne les salariés du privé ne soient
pas demandés de façon absolument
symétrique aux agents de la fonction
publique ce sera le cas pour l'âge
d'ouverture des droits ce sera le cas
pour l'accélération de la durée de
cotisation ensuite un principe de
cohérence nous avons préservé et
conserver les caractéristiques
fondamentales du système de retraite
pour les agents de la fonction publique
sur le calcul sur les six derniers mois
calcule sur la rémunération indiciaire
des fonctionnaires ce que nous
conservons aussi c'est le principe des
catégories actives à tout point de vue
nous en conservons le principe mais nous
conservons aussi la durée de service
pour les catégories actives et Olivier
du socle l'a rappelé pour les catégories
actives comme pour les agences
sédentaires nous ne modifions pas l'âge
d'annulation de la décode c'est le cas
pour tous les agents de la fonction
publique et puis le troisième principe
c'est un principe de progrès parce que
en supprimant cet article 7 ce sont des
améliorations du système et des progrès
pour les fonctionnaires contre lequel
vous voteriez je veux en mentionner de
façon très rapide trois qui sont
contenus dans ce texte d'abord la
portabilité des droits pour les agents
publics qui sont dans les catégories
actives la situation actuelle c'est que
si vous changez de métier quand vous
êtes policier que vous devenez par
exemple douaniers ou agent de la
pénitentiaire vous perdez tout le
bénéfice de vos années passées en tant
que policier ou dans la fonction
publique pénitentiaire et bien grâce à
l'article 7 nous mettons fin à cette
situation injuste plus injuste encore
votant contre l'article 7 vous viendriez
voter contre une mesure qui est la
suppression de la clause d'achèvement la
suppression de la cause d'assèvement ça
peut paraître technique quand on le dit
comme ça mais c'est un principe qui
existe dans le système de retraite
actuel qui consiste à faire en sorte que
vous ne bénéficiez des mesures qui
concernent les catégories actives
si vous terminez votre carrière en tant
que catégorie actif c'est-à-dire dans le
métier pénible c'est-à-dire tout
l'inverse de ce que nous devons faire
pour aménager les fins de carrière et
bien dans cet article 7 on le votant
vous allez supprimer la clause
d'achèvement je citerai une troisième
amélioration elle concerne les
contractuels de la fonction publique 20%
des agents publics aujourd'hui les
contractuels qui aujourd'hui font
parfois le même métier que les agents
publics qui sont intégrés actives mais
qui ne bénéficient pas des mesures de
protection qui concernent les agents des
catégories actives et bien avec
l'article 7 vous feront vous ferez en
sorte que les agents contractuels dès
lors qu'ils seront titularisés dans la
fonction publique ils verront leurs
années passées en tant que contact
actuel parfois 5 ans parfois 6 ans je
pense au plus de 100 000 agents
contractuels qui sont des
aides-soignants à l'hôpital et bien vous
ferez en sorte que ces années passées
elles contront et elles seront intégrées
dans les années de service quand ils
seront intitulés à réserves en fonction
publique voilà des avancées qui sont
inclus dans l'article 7 et autant de
bonnes raisons de donner un avis
défavorable aux amendements de
suppression de ce même article 7
du gouvernement avis défavorable de la
commission j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par la commission les
groupes communistes républicains
citoyens écologiques comme socialiste et
le groupe écologie solidarité et
territoire je rappelle qu'il porte sur
les amendements identiques de
suppression d'explication de vote
monsieur dessus
oui merci monsieur le Président mais je
voudrais dire au rapporteur qui était
pas avec nous toute la nuit hier mais
que des amendements de solidarité on en
a posé un certain nombre qu'ils ont été
tous balayés mais oui nous aimons la
solidarité la vraie c'est qu'il fallait
payer ceux qui profitent le plus alors
j'ai déjà expliqué la la situation de
blocage démocratique dans laquelle nous
étions ce soir et et vous avez commencé
ce débat hier et avant-hier pour refuser
tout autre mode de financement
alternatif avec logique du travail et
plus pour les français pour les
travailleurs vous éloignez une fois de
plus l'horizon du répit avec cette
réforme du décalage de l'âge de départ à
la retraite l'horizon de la vie enfin
sortie de la course à la production pour
nous écologistes cette réforme va donc à
rebours de tous les enjeux du moment de
tous les enjeux du siècle et je reprends
les propos de d'Olivier Véran vous avez
d'autres urgences à gérer nous avons nos
urgences à gérer le défi climatique doit
être la priorité absolue qui devrait
nous immobiliser qu'il aurait dû l'usé
ici soir et weekend s'il le faut mais
qui devrait ne mobiliser beaucoup plus
que cette réforme visant à faire
travailler toujours plus
travailler plus c'est produire plus
c'est extraire plus c'est polluer plus
faites pour servir un modèle économique
insatiable des structures du climat
cette réforme des retraites va à rebours
de l'urgence la vraie les rapports du
corps sont beaucoup moins inquiétants
que les rapports du GIEC beaucoup moins
précis sur l'avenir aussi beaucoup moins
implacable sur notre destin commun si la
retraite par répartition doit être
renforcée c'est parce que c'est un
système de solidarité entre les
générations et si nous devons repenser
nos modes de production et notre rapport
au travail c'est aussi dans une logique
intergénérationnelle de protection des
générations futures votre réforme
participe à une logique qui épuise
l'humain et la planète en visant des
objectifs insoutenables de croissance
fini dans un monde infini non l'inverse
dans une croissance infinie dans un
monde fini c'est pourquoi nous sommes
écologistes et nous refusons votre
logique obsolète et appelons à la
suppression de cet article que Monsieur
Breuillet
voilà nous avons eu 77 amendements de
suppression qui ont été présentés il y a
ensuite eu la vie de la commission la
vie du gouvernement on passe maintenant
aux explications de vote chaque sénateur
dispose d'une explication de vote de 2
minutes et on voit que de nombreux
sénateurs de gauche s'inscrivent pour
ces explications
et c'est donc une réforme pour les
femmes
c'est donc une réforme pour les
fonctionnaires
c'est donc une réforme pour les jeunes
c'est donc une réforme pour les ouvriers
pour les infirmières pour les
aides-soignants pour tous les métiers
pénibles mais ni les femmes ni les
fonctionnaires ni les jeunes ni les
infirmières ni les aides-soignants ni
tous ceux qui ont un métier pénible ne
la soutiennent quel ingratitude quel
ingratitude de ce peuple qui refuse une
réforme de progrès que vous nous
présentez et non seulement ils ne disent
pas seulement comme monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable ils disent
retraites
monsieur Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
c'est un rappel aux règlements monsieur
le Président à partir c'est sur la base
de l'article 38 77 amendements de
suppression
monsieur le Président je demande cette
application
donc je suis saisi par Monsieur
autaillou président de groupe des
d'une demande de clôture sur les
explications de vote sur les amendements
numéro 3 à 2268 en application de
l'Afrique 38 de notre règlement la
clôture peut être proposée lorsque au
moins deux orateurs c'est le cas d'avis
contraire sont intervenus et je peux
donner la parole s'il le souhaite à un
opérateur par groupe
et un sénateur qui figure sur la liste
donc un groupe qui souhaite prendre la
parole
monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
après avoir entendu la litanie des
orateurs qui sont succédés pour plaider
pour plaider
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'arguments
similaires
que sont succédé je me dis que
j'aimerais bien être petite souris à la
prochaine réunion du Parti socialiste
européen parce que j'ai entendu
description de l'Apocalypse
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme et
ce faisant vous disqualifiez aussi des
gens comme premier ministre Costa le
président Sanchez qui ont conduit ce
type de réformes et donc eugouverne eux
ont été réélus eux ont assumé
et c'est je crois là une grande
différence avec effectivement votre
positionnement
Lionel Jospin est-il revenu sur la
réforme Balladur non François
Hollande est-il revenu sur la réforme
verte non il a quelques petits
aménagements
reviendrez-vous sur l'article 7 s'il est
voté la réponse est non vous l'avez
d'ailleurs décrit comme une sorte
d'impôt sur la vie on sait bien que les
impôts vous les baissez jamais et donc
vous ne reviendrez jamais naturellement
là-dessus alors je vais paraphraser le
collègue Lucien Stanzione qui disait
ayez du courage et bien ayez du courage
retirer ses amendements de suppression
parce que vous ne reviendrez pas dessus
et donc pour le groupe RDPI en tout état
de cause nous votre compte parce que
c'est grand écarts permanents non
seulement ça fait mal aux adducteurs
mais ça fait mal à la confiance dans la
politique je rappelle que nous sommes
sur un débat de clôture madame la
Présidente et donc j'ai compris que vous
étiez favorable à la clôture en même
temps voilà madame la presse
dans la vrai dire nous ne sommes pas
surpris par cette proposition de clôture
de notre discussion elle parcourt quand
même les couloirs du Sénat depuis
quelques heures maintenant parmi
d'ailleurs d'autres rumeurs qui
circulent qui circulent aussi
ce recours je vous le dis sincèrement se
recourt à cette procédure est un acte de
faiblesse de la part de la droite
sénatoriale c'est une marque de
[Musique]
fébrile elle pas court les rangs du
gouvernement je au nom d'une soi-disante
obstruction que nous en petite musique
que nous entendons depuis depuis le
début depuis le début de l'examen de ce
projet de loi vous juger d'une procédure
monsieur le Président qui est peu usité
ici au Sénat et ce à quelques heures
d'une magnifique
mobilisation dans le pays et l'annonce
d'une autre grande mobilisation
samedi prochain monsieur Lemoine nous
avons du courage
mais vous vous perdez votre sang-froid
avec ce coup de force
que nous dénonçons je le dis aussi
crûment que je le pense cette procédure
est une attaque contre la démocratie et
les droits du Parlement ce n'est pas
digne du Sénat monsieur le Président
alors parce
que
lors des débats dans les prochaines
heures nous demandons avec les
présidents de gauche c'est à dire
moi-même le président kadner et le
président en compta la Réunion immédiate
d'une conférence des présidents
nous poursuivons monsieur le Président
Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
pour indiquer que bien entendu de votre
emploi la clôture puisque cela fait 5
jours et 5 nuits que nous avons à faire
à une obstruction je voudrais
dire que
l'Obs et l'année du rôle du Parlement
bien sûr le rôle du Parlement c'est de
débattre mais de débattre pour voter on
a été lu non pas pour faire des groupes
de parole mais pour voter
l'obstruction c'est une sorte d'auto
effacement
d'autodestissement du Parlement vous
allez refuser puisque on va intrins
d'escargot de voir et de voter sur
l'ensemble du texte par exemple sur les
petites retraites par exemple sur
l'usure professionnelle par exemple sur
le handicap au travail et bien nous nous
voulons je crois que choisir de ne pas
voter c'est choisir de ne pas peser
méfiez-vous bien que l'obstruction ne
mène pas à alimenter l'anti
parlementarisme parce que les Français
vont constater qu'à force de discuter le
Parlement ne sert à rien oui voilà pour
ces